GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE WORKING
TO GET STARTED I KNOW COUPLE OF
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO BE DROPPING
IN A BIT LATE.
SO FEW OTHERS HAVE ALREADY COME
FROM THERE ATTENDANCE.
AND DOT SO THANK YOU AND WELCOME
TO.
WHAT WILL BE OUR SECOND THAT
DON'T LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
CLIMATE CHANGE POLICIES?
I AM ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA CHAIR IN THIS COMMITTEE
AND DUH BELIEVE OF.
HENRY STERN NOW IS THE VICE
CHAIR NUBIAN.
IN A FEW MINUTES A YOU ALL HAVE
A COPY OF THE AGENDA. AND I'LL
START WITH TO SOME OPENING
REMARKS AT GOOD AFTERNOON AND
WELCOME TO THIS INFORMATION
HEARING ON THE URBAN FORESTRY.
AND URBAN GREENING PROGRAMS
FUNDED BY THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND.
AS ONE OF THE LEGISLATORS IN AND
MY COLLEAGUES HERE AS WELL
INVOLVED IN THE PASSAGE OF
SENATE BILL FIVE. LAST YEAR I
BELIEVE GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE IS
A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THE
HEALTHY AND RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S WHY WE INCLUDED URBAN
FORESTRY IN URBAN GREENING IN
THE FINAL PART BOND. I LAST
YEAR.
BECAUSE IT A MUCH MORE NEEDS TO
BE DONE PARTICULARLY IN OUR
DISADVANTAGE IN LOW INCOME AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
THE VISION OF FOR THAT BOND HAS
NEVER BEEN.
TO REPLACE THE CLIMATE
INVESTMENTS FOR THESE PROGRAMS
BUT TO ADD ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
OUR TO THE PROGRAMS THAT WE WANT
TO. WILL HIGHLIGHT AND EMPHASIZE
THAT TODAY OR AS A SIMPLETON
WOULD SAY UNDERSCORE. HIGHLIGHT.
YOU KNOW ALL THAT. ALL OF THOSE
THAT TERMINOLOGY CITY USE THAT
THAT THAT. HOW HAPPY TO SEE
RECENT GROUNDBREAKING EVENTS IN
MY OWN DISTRICT GOD THAT WERE
FUNDED BY THESE PROGRAMS IN
NORTH SHORE? THIS THE COMMUNITY
OF NORTH SHORE THIS WOULD BE THE
FIRST PARK EVER BUILT IN THAT
COMMUNITY OUT BY THE SALTON SEA
IN THE CITY OF EL CENTRO.
THAT FOR MANY YEARS HAS BEEN
LACKING IN PARK.
A GREAT AND OF COURSE.
SERVING THE COMMUNITIES IN THAT
AREA BOTH RURAL COMMUNITIES THAT
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
BUILD THE PARKS. IF IT WASN'T
FOR THESE PARTICULAR PROGRAMS.
THROUGH THESE PROGRAMS WE ARE
SEEING SMALL INVESTMENTS MAKE
BIG
CHANGES FOR COMMUNITIES MOST
IMPACTED BY CLIMATE CHANGE.
WHOEVER IS CLIMATE CHANGE
PROGRESSES WE WILL BE
INCREASINGLY RELIANT ON GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE TO HELP MITIGATE
THE IMPACTS. OF INCREASED
BUILDING ENERGY DEMANDS AND
INCONSISTENT WATER SUPPLIES AND
URBAN HEAT. ISLAND EFFECT
TODAY WE ARE HERE TO FOCUS ON
THE INVESTMENTS FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
OUR GOAL IS TO UNDERSTAND. WHAT
IS HAPPENING WITH THESE PREVIOUS
BUDGET ALLOCATIONS WHERE THE
PROGRAM'S KURDISTAN AND WHAT
IMPACT THESE PROGRAMS ARE HAVING
ON OUR STATES CLIMATE GOALS?
I'M VERY PLEASED THAT WE HAVE
SUCH AN ARRAY OF EXPERTS ON
THESE PROGRAMS HERE WITH US
TODAY. AND I KNOW.
I'D LIKE TO INVITE OUR FIRST
PANEL TO JOIN US AT THE TABLE
AND TURNED IT OVER. ATTIRE VICE
CHAIR WHO'S NOT HERE HE WILL BE
HERE.
FOR OPENING COMMENTS WHEN HE
GETS HERE HASSELBLAD.
BUT I THE FIRST PANEL COME UP.
AND DOUBLE JUMP RIGHT IN.
SO MY NAME IS HAL YANG I'M
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR.
DEPARTMENT FOR DOWN FIRE
PROTECTION CAL FIRE.
AND THE. I LIKE TO COVER.
COUPLE THINGS TODAY JUST AN
OVERVIEW OF THE PROGRAM FIRST
AND THEN THE COUPLE.
OF EXAMPLES OF THE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA'S URBAN A COMMUNITY
FORCE YOUR PROGRAM THAT WAS
CREATED WITH THE PASSAGE OF THE
URBAN FORESTRY ACT. SEVENTY
EIGHT.
IT HAS BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
SINCE THEN.
IT FOCUSES ON INCREASING TREE
CANOPY.
AND MANAGING EXISTING CANOPIES
IN THE MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE'S.
WE ALSO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THROUGH.
ARE.
ARTICLE WITH STAFF THAT INCLUDES
REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL
FORESTERS AND CERTIFIED
ARBORIST.
AND.
IN ADDITION TO.
CLEANING THE AIR AND STORING
CARBON THIS PROGRAM HAS REALLY
SHOWN ITSELF TO MAKE A REAL
DIFFERENCE IN THE QUALITY OF
LIFE OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ALMOST
WITHOUT FAIL ALSO HAVE THE
LOWEST TREE CANOPY COVER.
AND THIS CAN THE CLEARLY SHOWN
ON MAPS SHOWING A RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN.
TREE CANOPY AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
AND THIS IS OBVIOUSLY AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUE
WHICH IMPACTS THE MOST
VULNERABLE. NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE
STATE.
WITH PARKING LOTS STREETS AND
PARKS THAT ARE SHADED BY TREES
PEOPLE ARE MUCH MORE LIKELY TO.
WALK INSTEAD OF DRIVE AND SPEND
TIME OUTDOORS WITH FAMILY AND
FRIENDS.
IN ADDITION TO THE DIRECT
GREENHOUSE GAS BENEFITS.
THERE ARE SOME OTHER ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS OF.
URBAN TREES SUCH AS SIR ENERGY
CONSERVATION.
THEY IMPROVE AIR QUALITY.
THEY INCREASED COMMERCIAL
ACTIVITY IN BUSINESS DISTRICTS.
THE INCREASE.
PUBLIC HELPED AND THEY GENERALLY
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE.
SO THE BOTTOM LINE TAKE HOME
MESSAGE IS THAT TREES IN URBAN
COMMUNITIES.
THIS STORE CARBON DAY REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
THEY MAKE A REAL TANGIBLE
POSITIVE DIFFERENCE IN PEOPLE'S
LIVES.
AND THIS POSITIVE DIFFERENCE IS
MOST PRONOUNCED IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
SO OUR PROGRAM PROVIDES
TECHNICAL FINANCIAL RESEARCH AND
EDUCATIONAL ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
NONPROFITS COMMUNITY GROUPS.
PRIVATE BUSINESSES AND THE
PUBLIC AT LARGE.
AND THE TYPES OF GRANTS THAT WE
HAVE GIVEN OUT
TYPICALLY INCLUDE URBAN TREE
PLANTING AND MAINTENANCE URBAN
TREE IN THE TORIES.
URBAN WOOD UTILIZATION AND
FORCED MANAGEMENT PLANS.
IN TOTAL CAL FIRES
A COMMUNITY FORESTRY PROGRAM
THAT'S ON THE GROUNDS TOTALING.
THIRTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO DATE IN
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE INVESTMENT
FUNDS.
AND THE THERE'S CLEARLY STILL A
NEED.
A RECENT DATA INDICATE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S URBAN AREAS HAVE
ONLY FIFTEEN PERCENT OF THE LAND
AREA COVERED IN THREE COUNT UP
THE ON THE AVERAGE.
AND THIS IS.
ACTUALLY AMONG THE LOWEST OF OF
ALL STATES IN THE NATION.
SO CLEARLY THERE ARE AND
NUMEROUS OPPORTUNITIES TO PLANT
MILLIONS MORE URBAN PIECING
CALIFORNIA'S URBAN AREAS.
AND THE URBAN FORESTS ARE.
THERE ARE PART OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF URBAN AREAS
DID PROVIDE ECOSYSTEM SERVICES
SAYS WALLACE ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
CALL BENEFITS.
SO AS OPPOSED TO OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE ELEMENTS ALL OF
WHICH DEPRECIATING VALUES.
TREES ACTUALLY APPRECIATE IN
VALUE US TO GET LARGER AND OLDER
THEY BECOME MORE VALUABLE.
SO A AND DEMANDING TIME I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW
NOTABLE PROJECTS ACROSS THE
STATE THAT WE FELT WERE
SUCCESSFUL. THEY'RE LOCATED IN
RICHMOND SANDIEGO OR SAID THAT
AND EL CENTRO.
THE CITY OF RICHMOND A PLANTED
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY TREES AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
BY THE CITY AND ITS NONPROFIT
PARTNERS AND THEIR NEWLY TRAINED
LOCAL RESIDENTS AND STUDENTS.
COLLABORATION WITH THE FOR
NONPROFITS INSURED COVERING A
WIDE RANGE OF DISADVANTAGED
NEIGHBORHOODS.
THE TREES WILL BE ACTIVELY
MAINTAINED BY THE CITY IN THE
LONG TERM AND THEY WILL HELP
LOCAL AIR QUALITY.
AND SAN DIEGO AND CHULA VISTA.
THERE WAS A RELATIVELY NEW NON
PROFITS
WHICH IS PART TUNING WITH THE
URBAN CORE OF SAN DIEGO AND
OTHERS TO PLANT AND MAINTAIN
TWELVE HUNDRED TREATS.
THROUGHOUT THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED. THAT'S OF TRACKS
IN THE TWO CITIES.
THEY'RE ALSO MODIFYING
INFRASTRUCTURE WHEN NECESSARY TO
CREATE HIGH QUALITY THREE
PLANTING SITES WHICH ARE
SOMETIMES LACKING IN THIS AREA.
IN ADDITION TREE SAN DIEGO IS
CREATING AT THREE STEWARDS
PROGRAM.
FAN LOCAL RESIDENTS IN HOW TO
CONTINUE CARING FOR THE TREES
AFTER GRANT.
THE CITY OF EL CENTRO.
IT'S REALLY A SUCCESSFUL
COOPERATIVE PROJECT BETWEEN AL
CENTRAL HALT BILL CALEXICO
IMPERIAL AND BRAWLING.
IT CREATES SHADY PLACES FOR
RESIDENTS TO WRECK CREATE AND
GATHER. OBVIOUSLY A VERY
IMPORTANT IN THESE DESERT
CITIES.
THE PROJECT THIS PLANTING AND
MAINTAINING FOURTEEN HUNDRED
DESERT CLIMATE APPROPRIATE TREES
THROUGH THE FIVE CITY AREA.
AND WILL BE LOCATED ALMOST
ENTIRELY AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
THE GRANT US RESULTED IN
EXCELLENT COOPERATION.
AND AMONG THE CITY'S INVOLVED.
AND FINALLY THE CITY A MERCED.
PLANTING.
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY TREES THAT
SORT OF SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY.
AS WELL AS DEVELOPING A URBAN
FOREST MANAGEMENT PLAN.
AND THE INVENTORY MANAGEMENT
PLAN WILL ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION TRUE
URBAN FORCED EXPANSION IN THE
FUTURE.
SO.
ENCLOSING WE FEEL THAT.
THE URBAN AND COMMUNITY
FORESTRY PROGRAM AND CAL FIRE
CONTINUES TO BE HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL.
IN ADDITION TO ALSO MAKING.
TANGIBLE POSITIVE DIFFERENCES IN
PEOPLE LIVES PEOPLE'S LIVES
NOTABLY IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
THE PROGRAM IS GOING TO REDUCE
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND METRIC TONS OF CO TWO
EQUIVALENTS.
AND.
WITHOUT
I'LL HAND OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
TO LEE AND BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLY.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
PARTICIPATE TODAY MY NAME'S
JULIE ALVIS AND DEPUTY ASSISTANT
SECRETARY OF NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY.
AND.
WE ADMINISTER THE URBAN
GREENING PROGRAM ONE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE INVESTMENT
PROGRAMS.
CITY BEGAN I THOUGHT I WOULD
EXPLAIN WHAT THE PROGRAM
CONSIDERS TO BE AN URBAN
GREENING PROJECT.
URBAN GREENING PROJECTS CONVERT
EXISTING URBAN HARD SCAPES AND
TWO GREEN SPACES THAT USE.
I NATURAL AND GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE APPROACHES
TO CREATE SUSTAINABLE AND MORE
VIBRANT COMMUNITIES.
AND THE COMPETITIVE PROJECTS
MAXIMIZE OPPORTUNITIES TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THROUGH
THEIR PROJECT DESIGN. AND SOME
EXAMPLES OF ELIGIBLE URBAN
GREENING PROJECTS INCLUDE THE
ESTABLISHMENT ENHANCEMENT
EXPANSION OF NEIGHBORHOOD PARKS
AND COMMUNITY SPACES. THE
GREENING OF PUBLIC LANDS
INSTRUCTION AT THE END AS
STRUCTURES INCLUDING
SCHOOLYARDS.
GREEN STREET AN ALLEYWAY
PROJECTS.
AND THE CREATION OF NON
MOTORIZED URBAN TRAILS THAT
PROVIDE SAFE ROUTES
BETWEEN AND RESIDENCES
WORKPLACES COMMERCIAL CENTERS
AND SCHOOLS.
AND THEN ALSO PROJECTS THAT I'M
HELP WITH OUR URBAN HEAT ISLAND
MITIGATION AND ENERGY
CONSERVATION.
ALL COMPETITIVE PROJECTS MUST
INCLUDE A COMPONENT THAT REDUCES
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
THIS IS ACHIEVED BY RECRUITING
IN YOUR PROJECT DESIGNED THE
PLANTING OF TREES TO SEQUESTER
CARBON.
OR THE STRATEGIC PLANTING OF
TREES ARM NEXT TO BUILDINGS
REDUCE OUR ENERGY USE IN THOSE
BUILDINGS.
AND OR BY CONSTRUCTING WALKING
A BICYCLE PASSED REDUCE VEHICLE
TRIPS
AND MANY OF OUR PROJECTS I.
ADDED CONTAINED A NUMBER OF
THOSE APPROACHES.
ALL COMPETITIVE PROJECTS ALSO
PROVIDE MULTIPLE BENEFIT SO THAT
IN ADDITION TO GHG REDUCTIONS.
THEY ARE ALSO PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CAPTURING
WATER COOLING ENVIRONMENTS
REDUCING ENERGY AND PROVIDING
PARK IN OPEN SPACE FOR HABITAT
AND RECREATION.
BEYOND GHG REDUCTIONS IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS OF THE
PROJECTS.
THE PROJECTS THAT ARE MOST
COMPETITIVE ALSO PROVIDE
ECONOMIC SOCIAL AND HEALTH
BENEFITS FOR COMMUNITIES. THESE
BENEFITS CAN INCLUDE WORKFORCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING
CONTRACTING AND JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
INCREASED ACCESS TO NATURAL
ENVIRONMENTS.
I'M INCREASED ACCESS TO LOCALLY
GROWN FOOD SOURCES PHYSICAL.
ACTIVITY OPPORTUNITIES AND THIS
IS JUST TO NAME A FEW.
IN ADDITION STRONG COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS AND SUPPORT IS
VITAL TO THE COMPETITIVE
APPLICATIONS IN OUR PROGRAM.
IN ROUND ONE.
OF OUR PROGRAM IN NOVEMBER
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND WE RECENTLY
AWARDED SEVENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN. FISCAL YEAR AT
TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN FUNDING
TO THIRTY NINE PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS NOW OF
ENTERING INTO GRANT AGREEMENTS
AND ANTICIPATE THAT MOST OF
THESE CAPITAL PROJECTS.
WILL BE FULLY COMPLETED AND
TWENTY TWENTY.
THE PROGRAM RECEIVED A TOTAL OF
ONE HUNDRED FORTY THREE
APPLICATIONS REQUESTING THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING.
AFTER A MULTI DISCIPLINARY.
TECHNICAL REVIEW PANEL SCORED
APPLICATIONS WE ARE STAFF
VISITED.
FIFTY PROJECTS.
AND WHICH IS PART OF THE PROCESS
OF OUR GRANT AWARD CYCLE. AND
FOLLOWING THE SITE VISITS THIRTY
NINE PROJECTS WERE RECOMMENDED
FOR FUNDING.
NINETY TWO PERCENT OF THE FUNDS
WERE AWARDED TO PROJECTS LOCATED
IN AND BENEFITTING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES HER S. B. FIVE
THIRTY FIVE. AND USING CALLIN
VIRUS GRAIN. THE REQUIRED TARGET
FOR PROGRAM WAS SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT.
SOME STATISTICS FROM THIS FIRST
ROUNDS.
INCLUDE.
SIX THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY EIGHT TREES TO BE
PLANTED.
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SIX METRIC TONS OF CO
TWO ACQUITTALS LEE REDUCED.
FIVE ONE HUNDRED NINETY THREE
ACRE FEET OF STORM WATERCAPTURE.
THREE HUNDRED AND NINETY EIGHT
NINETY ONE ACRES OF ODD GREEN
SPACE OPEN SPACE CREATED. AND
FORTY TWO MILES OF COMMUTER
TRAIL TO BE ADDED.
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE LIKELY
OTHER COMPONENTS TO THESE
PROJECTS THAT FURTHER REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. BUT
ARE NOT QUANTIFIED AT THIS TIME
SUCH AS CARBON SEQUESTRATION
FROM OTHER VEGETATION WATER
ENERGY SAVINGS REDUCED ENERGY
USE FROM CREATING COOLER
ENVIRONMENTS.
AND THEN.
CONTRIBUTING TO THE OVERALL
CHANGE IN HOW PEOPLE ARE MOVING
THROUGH THEIR COMMUNITIES BY
ADDING IN LINKING TO AYE OTHER
WHITE WALKING AND BIKING
OPPORTUNITIES. SO THE ADDITIONAL
JEAN GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS
BEYOND WHAT IS ONLY MEASURED
WITHIN THE PROJECT AREA.
SOME SAMPLE PROJECTS I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT FROM THE FIRST ROUND
ALSO ANOTHER PROJECT IN THE CITY
OF RICHMOND. IT'S CALLED GREEN
IN THE YELLOW BRICK ROAD.
THIS PROJECTS
IS ADDING ONE MILE OF BIKE AND
PEDESTRIAN PATH PATHS AND
PLANTING TREES INSTALLING STORM
WATER PLANTERS. BIAS WHALES
PULLED OUT SOME TRAFFIC CALMING
FEATURES. IT BUILDS UPON ELEVEN
YEARS OF COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
AND CONNECTS TO EXISTING PARKS.
WITH STRONG RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN THE COMMUNITY AND ITS
PARTNERS.
ANOTHER PROJECT THAT RECEIVE
FUNDING FROM.
WOULD IN LOS ANGELES THE LOS
ANGELES NEIGHBORHOODS LAND
TRUST.
I'VE FOR THE WISHING TREE PARK
THIS WILL ACTIVATE NEW COMMUNITY
SPACE BY DEVELOPING A FORMER
BROWNFIELD SITE AND TO EIGHT
POINT FIVE. ACRES OF FATTY PARK.
AND THE FORMER BROWNFIELD SITE
WAS PREVIOUSLY OWNED BY CHEVRON
FULLY REMAIN REMEDIATED.
ANOTHER NEIGHBORHOOD TRIP AND
PROJECT.
AND THEN FINALLY AND YOU ALLUDED
TO EARLIER WE'RE HAPPY TO AWARD
TO THE CITY OF NORTH SHORE FOR
THE NORTH SHORE COMMUNITY PARK.
SAYS A PROJECT TO CREATE NEW
MULTI USE PARK INCLUDING TREES
DROUGHT TOLERANT PLANTS.
PATTERSON PARK AMENITIES ON THIS
IS A SHOVEL READY PROJECTS
STRONG COMMUNITY SUPPORT STRONG
MATCH.
ANOTHER VERY GOOD PROJECTS.
AND WE HAVE JUST BEGUN OUR
SECOND ROUND OF THE PROGRAM THE
PROGRAM HAS TWENTY FOUR POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AND LOCAL
ASSISTANCE TO AWARD. OUR
SOLICITATION OPENED IN LATE
JANUARY AND OUR FIRST WORKSHOP
WAS HELD YESTERDAY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. OUR STAFF WILL BE
HOLDING EIGHT WORKSHOPS IN TOTAL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WILL NEXT
BE IN LYNNWOOD THAN INDIA รณ
OAKLAND. FAST SALIA READING SAN
DIEGO AND ONTARIO.
OUR APPLICATIONS AND THE
APPLICATIONS ARE DUE IN MID
APRIL AND AWARDS ARE EXPECTED
AND FALL TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
SO JUST LIKE TO CLOSE.
BY SAYING THAT.
.
WHAT'S REALLY SATISFYING ABOUT
ADMINISTERING THIS PROGRAM.
WE DO GO OUT OF COURSE TO VISIT
THE SITES YOU KNOW PRIOR TO
CHOOSING PROJECTS TO AWARD AND
TO SEE. THE VISION OF THE
COMMUNITY THAT'S THERE YOU SEE
THE SITE. AND THE POTENTIAL THAT
IT HAS AND THEN TO COME BACK
YEARS LATER TO SEE IT
MATERIALIZE AND A REAL ASSET TO
THE COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OUT YOU KNOW I WAS GONNA ASK
QUESTION HOW MANY APPLICATIONS.
SUBMITTED AND YOU YOU
HIGHLIGHTED THAT HUNDRED FORTY
THREE.
AND OVERSUBSCRIBED
SIGNIFICANTLY.
FOR THE MONEY THAT WAS
AVAILABLE BUT SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION SENATOR DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
NO.
I WILL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION I'LL GO AHEAD AND
CALL OF DIEM NEXT.
A GROUP OF PANELISTS.
FOR US WE HAVE A MERRY CHRISTMAS
AND CINDY BLAME.
I LEAN OVER LAW SCHOOL DEBORAH
WEINSTEIN BLOOM AND.
MR IGOR.
LUCK ON.
ME THIS MATTER
EVERYONE
.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME. FAME
KILL AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING I THINK WE
ARE ALL FROM A STAKEHOLDER
PERSPECTIVE REALLY GRATEFUL FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM THE IMPACTS ON THE
VALUE.
I'M MARY CHRISTMANN I'M WITH THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC.
WE ARE A NATIONAL ORGANIZATION
THAT'S WORKING TO CREATE HEALTHY
CLIMATE SMART COMMUNITIES WITH
ACCESS TO MAJOR FOR ALL AND
WE'VE BEEN DOING IMPLEMENTATION
URBAN DRAINING PROJECTS FOR OVER
FORTY FIVE YEARS THAT ACTUALLY.
ARE FOUNDATION OUR HISTORY WHAT
OUR WORK IS REALLY BUILT ON I'M
AND WE'RE THRILLED ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM I'M AND REALLY EXCITED
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
VALUE IN THE NEED FOR THE WORK.
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THE PART THE
REASON THIS PROGRAM IS SO
VALUABLE IS USE OUR CURRENT
URBAN DESIGN IS HURTING US IT'S
HURTING OUR NEIGHBORHOODS?
WE HAVE GRAY INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
INCREASES CLIMATE IMPACTS
INCREASES HEAT INCREASES
POLLUTION AND AARON WATER ON IT
IS ACTUALLY HURTING US AND HAS
FETAL IMPACTS.
THAT'S AREALITY THIS IS A
PROGRAM THAT IS CATALYZING AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR COMMUNITIES TO
RE ENVISION THE ROLE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
RE ENVISION THE ROLE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE AYE TO
PROVIDE HEALTHY CONNECTED AND
CLIMATE RESILIENT COMMUNITIES
THIS IS UNIQUE WE DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF OTHER PROGRAMS THAT DO
THIS. IN ADDITION I WOULD REALLY
SAY THAT THIS PROGRAM MARY'S AND
MITIGATION AND ADAPTATION IN A
SPECIAL WAY BUT THROUGH THE
INVESTMENTS NOT ONLY DO WE GET
LOW CARBON COMMUNITIES BUT WE
ALSO GET ADAPTED COMMUNITIES.
THAT ARE ABLE TO WEATHER SUITS
STREAM WEATHER EVENTS ON AN
IMPORTANT WAY I'M AND WERE
ALREADY SEEING THOSE.
WE ARE NOT READY FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE
I THINK WE WOULD ALL AGREE WITH
THAT I THINK I CONSTITUENTS IN
YOUR DISTRICTS WOULD REALLY FEEL
THE IMPACTS AND ARTICULATE
FEELING THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND A SEVERE WAY RIGHT
NOW.
WE ARE READY AND WE DON'T HAVE
POTS OF MONEY THAT ARE
INTEGRATING AYE CHANGING IN
TRANSFORMING OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR HEALTHY CONNECTED
COMMUNITIES AND THIS IS ONE THAT
IS JUST GOTTEN STARTED WITH ONE
FIRST ROUND. OF INVESTMENTS AND
I THINK THE POTENTIAL IS
SIGNIFICANT I WANT TO JUST SAY
COUPLE STATS IN TERMS OF JUST
THE PURE GREENHOUSE GAS BENEFITS
OF THIS PROGRAM. I'M FIRST A
STUDY BY BERKELEY CITED THAT IF
WE WERE TO DO A COOL COMMUNITY
STRATEGY USING GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS I'M
ACROSS THE STATE THERE'S THE
OPPORTUNITY AT MINIMUM. TO
REDUCE CARBON EMISSIONS BY FOUR
MILLION TIMES ANNUALLY WE ALSO
HAVE A STUDY LOOKING AT THE BAY
AREA THAT IF WE WERE TO SHIFT
TRANSPORTATION MODES TO ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION THAT FIFTY
PERCENT OF ALL SHORT OR MEDIUM
INCOME TRIPS.
ARMS OF ONE TO FIVE MILES AYE
INTO ACTIVE TRANSORTATION WOULD
REDUCE CARBON EMISSIONS BY
FOURTEEN POINT FIVE PERCENT. AND
REDUCE DIABETES AND
CARDIOVASCULAR OF VASCULAR
DISEASE BY FOURTEEN PERCENT.
WE ALSO HAVE AN ANALYSIS FROM
THE CITY OF LA WHERE THEY'VE
LOOKED AT. LARGE SCALE
TRANSFORMATION OF THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE TO GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO THEN LOCALLY SOURCED
THIRTY FIVE TO FORTY PERCENT OF
THEIR WATER.
THESE ARE REAL IMPACT ON THESE
ARE MULTIPLE BENEFIT IN THIS
DOESN'T EVEN SPEAK TO THE
REALITY OF CLEAN AIR
CLEANER WATER. MORE RECREATION
I'M HEALTHIER COMMUNITIES ALL
THE THINGS WE KNOW WE NEED IN
TERMS OF AYE DAY INCREASED
IMPACTS WERE SAYING FROM FLOOD
TO WILDFIRE. AYE TO SEA LEVEL
RISE AND I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
WITH A COUPLE QUICK POINTS
ONE.
STATE PROGRAMS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO MORE THAN JUST
FIND IMPORTANT PRICE.
FUNDING IS REALLY IMPORTANT
BUT THE WAY WE STRATEGIZING CREE
INNOVATIVE PROJECTS LIKE THIS.
CATALYZES INNOVATION AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL ISN'T JUST ABOUT
FINDING THIS IS ABOUT SPURRING
INTERNALIZING INNOVATION
INTEGRATED AND ACROSS FUNCTIONAL
I INVESTMENTS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS PROGRAM HAD
DONE. IT INTEGRATED PLANNING.
I'M IN A NEW WAY FOR A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES THE OTHER THING I
WOULD SAY IS THAT THIS IS ONE OF
THE ONLY PROGRAMS FROM CAP AND
TRADE. THAT GOES TO WORK IN A
REALLY VISIBLE WAY IN
COMMUNITIES SO COMMUNITIES CAN
SEE THE IMPACT OF WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE TO CREATE LOW CARBON
COMMUNITIES FROM THE REVENUE OF
CAP TRADE.
THEY CAN WALK DOWN THE STREET
INVISIBLY SEE CHANGES.
ANOTHER POINT I WOULD MAKE IS A
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION WE ARE
WORKING WITH STATES ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY WERE LOOKING AT CURRENT
PRICING PROGRAMS.
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT HOW CAN
THEY CREATE THEIR OWN CLAIM A
PROBLEM POP UP POLICIES WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE BIG BY
SIGNIFICANT REVENUES GENERATED
IN CALIFORNIA. IN TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THEIR INVESTMENT
STRATEGY SHOULD BE AS ARE
LOOKING AT CLIMATE POLICIES ON
THIS HAVE TO BE PART OF THE
BLUEPRINTS.
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON WHO'S REALLY LOOKING
AT EVERY PIECE OF CALIFORNIA'S
POLICY TO THINK ABOUT HOW THEY
SHOULD DO IT. AND IF WE DO NOT
INCLUDE CRITICAL STRATEGIES LIKE
GREEN MULTIPLE BENEFIT GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND URBAN
GREENING THAT MEANS THAT ACROSS
THE WORLD WERE JURISDICTIONS ARE
LOOKING AT US FOR A MODEL.
THAT THEY'RE MISSING THAT
CRITICAL ESSENTIAL PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE
IN CREATING LOW CARB BANG
HEALTHY RESILIENT COMMUNITIES
ANSWERED THANK YOU FOR THE
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE I'M WE
REALLY ARE LOOKING FOR TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
I'M MAKING SURE THIS WORK
CONTINUES TO BE FUNDED.
GOING WITHOUT.
AND COVER UPS ARE GONNA COVER
THREE ASPECTS OF THE.
OF.
.
URBAN FORESTRY.
A FIRST A TO TALK ABOUT RELEASE
ROLE IN URBAN FORESTRY AND THEN
I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT ARE
GRANTING PROGRAMS ON A COUPLE OF
PROJECTS. UNLESS I'M GOING TO
COVER SOME OF THE ISSUES THE
KINDA CO BENEFITS PUBLIC HEALTH
CAPACITY BUILDING AND JOBS.
OF FOR THIRTY YEARS CALIFORNIA
LEAST BERNIE UMBRELLA
ORGANIZATION FOR. A URBAN FORCE
NONPROFITS GRASSROOTS NONPROFIT.
AND THE PLAN CARE FOR TREES IN
THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS USING A
MODEL BASED ON THE BELIEF THAT
TRUE CHANGE OCCURS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL WITH THE.
LOCAL RESIDENTS INVOLVED IN
MAKING DECISIONS AS YOU SAID
EARLIER SMALL INVESTMENTS MAKING
BIG CHANGES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
FROM THE NETWORK IT RIGHT NOW IS
ABOUT A HUNDRED STRONG AND
INCLUDES GROUPS LIKE TREE SAN
DIEGO URBAN RELIEF POINT THIS
TREE PEOPLE A CLEANER GREENER
EAST LA AND SEVERAL LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS.
WE PROVIDE EDUCATION ADVOCACY
AND BUT FOR THE NETWORK AND ANY
INTERESTED COMMUNITY BENEFIT
ORGANIZATION IT'S NOT JUST
SOMEBODY WHO NORMALLY PLANTS
TREES BUT ANY GROUP.
OUR PRIMARY STATEWIDE PARTNERS
IN THESE EFFORTS INCLUDE THE
GREEN LINING INSTITUTE THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY TRANSFORMING
HOUSING CALIFORNIA. THESE
PARTNERS WORK WITH US ON
INTEGRATED SOLUTIONS FOR SOCIAL
EQUITY AND SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE TO BRING
TREES TO THE COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEY'RE NEEDED MOST.
AND THAT MOST OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT PART ABOUT TREES THE
HEALTH BENEFITS OF THOSE TREES.
SO FOR THIRTY YEARS WE'VE ALSO
ADMINISTERED GRANTS.
CURRENTLY THE MAJORITY OF THESE
GRANTS ARE BEING SUPPORTED BY
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDING
BUT WE ALSO GET SOME FUNDING
FROM OTHER SOURCES.
TREES R. COST OF AND A COST
EFFECTIVE INVESTMENTS FOR
CAPTURING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS TO MITIGATE CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND FOR IMPROVING THE
HEALTH OF RESIDENTS BECAUSE
TREES ARE FILTERING. OUT
PARTICULATE MATTER.
NEAR HIGH TRAFFIC ROADWAYS
WHICH.
IS OVERLY BURDENED IN.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AS
WELL AS HELPING PROTECT URBAN
NEIGHBORHOODS FROM EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE BRINGS.
WITH EXTREME HEAT AND AIR
QUALITY BEING OF GREATEST
CONCERN TO PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AT THIS POINT
TIME.
AND AGAIN THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
OVERLY AFFECTS DISADVANTAGED
COMMITTEES BECAUSE YOU'RE
STARTING TO TALK ABOUT UTILITY
COSTS.
AND IF WE DON'T HAVE TREES WE
DON'T HAVE A DOUBLE
TRANSPIRATION AND ALL THOSE
COOLING.
BENEFITS.
SO TREES ARE CRITICAL COMPONENT
OF CLIMATE ADAPTATION TOOL KIT
FOR DESIGNING HEALTHY CITIES AND
BUILDING COOPER KENNEDY
RESILIENCY.
SO WHEN THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDING BECAME
AVAILABLE IN TWENTY FOURTEEN.
RELIEF FOCUSED ON DEVELOPING
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN COMMUNITY
GROUPS.
IN THE UNDERSERVED NEIGHBORHOODS
AND MORE ESTABLISHED URBAN
FOREST NONPROFITS
THE BUDDY SYSTEM ESSENTIALLY TO
SAY THAT WE NEEDED TO DEVELOP
CAPACITY FOR URBAN FORCE PROJECT
SENATOR RESOURCE NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND THIS WAS THE BEST WAY TO DO
IT.
WITH THE HELP OF LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS WE BEGAN A PROGRAM
OF DEEP OUT REACH INTO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. SO
THAT THE FUND WILL GO TO THOSE.
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS.
LET ME GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF THAT
TO ONE OF THEM IS.
.
A GREAT EXAMPLE THAT IS A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN AN URBAN
FORCED NONPROFIT URBAN RELIEF IN
OAKLAND. AND COMMUNITY BENEFIT
ORGANIZATION.
EPISCOPAL IMPACT FUND WORKING
IN ONE OF THE NEIGHBORHOODS.
PROGRAM IS CALLED GREEN SANTIAGO
AND OUR NEIGHBORS WHICH IS
PLANTING NINETY TWO TREES AND A
COMMUNITY GARDEN.
THE FISCAL IMPACT FUND IS ALSO
PART DURING WITH ENGLISH HE HAD
THE SANTIAGO LOW INCOME SPANISH
SPEAKING CONGREGATION THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY FOOD BANK WHICH
SERVES MOSTLY ASIAN. AMERICANS
AND INDIGENOUS PERMACULTURE A
GROUP WORKING ON FOOD SECURITY.
THIS THIS.
.
GETTING TOGETHER ADVERSE
PARTNERSHIPS IN COMMUNITIES IS
INCREDIBLY POWERFUL IN BRINGING
RESIDENTS TOGETHER. A FROM
DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS AND
STRENGTHENING THE COMMUNITY
OVER.
UP PLANTING TREES IS AN EASY
INTRODUCTION TO COMMUNITY
ACTIVISM AND ENVIRONMENTALISM.
AND HAS BEEN SHOWN IT HAS BEEN
SHOWN THE COMMUNITY ACTIVISM
LEADS TO CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AS
WELL AS LONG TERM STEWARDSHIP OF
THESE TREES.
.
TO CONTINUE AS FAR AS GRANT
SUPPORT.
IT'S IMPORTANT UNDERSCORE THE
UNIQUE WAYS IN WHICH URBAN
FORESTRY PROGRAM HAS BEEN ABLE
TO SUCCESSFULLY REACH AND
BENEFIT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
RELIEF HAS BEEN ABLE TO MODEL
AND SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT
CAPACITY BUILDING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL BY PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO SMALL GROUPS. THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE MISSED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BENEFIT FROM CAP
AND TRADE.
FOR SMALL COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS CAN BE A SERIOUS
CHALLENGE TO SUBMIT A GOVERNMENT
GRANT APPLICATION FOR HER IDEA
OF REASONS INCLUDING SIMPLY
AWARENESS ABOUT THE PROGRAM.
CAPACITY AND TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE.
BECAUSE WE DO PASSED THROUGH
GRANTS OR WE TAKE WE GET FUNDING
FROM. OTHER CAL FIRE AND WE DO
GRANTS TO THE SMALL
ORGANIZATIONS IN TWENTY SIXTEEN.
ONLY FORTY PERCENT OF THE
APPLICATIONS WE RECEIVED FROM
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WERE
ELIGIBLE TO BE REVIEWED. THAT
MEANT THEY HAD EVERYTHING THEY
NEEDED SIMPLY TO BE REVIEWED SO.
BECAUSE OUR MISSION IS TO
EMPOWER GRASSROOTS EFFORTS THAT
LED TO OUR POLICY OF SUPPORTING
GRANTEES TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
APPLICATIONS WERE ELIGIBLE.
WITHOUT YET TAKING INTO ACCOUNT
THE SUBSTANCE AND MERIT OF THE
APPLICATION. WE ARE LITERALLY
TEACHING GRANT.
OPERATION SKILLS AND BUILDING
CAPACITY.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THIS WILL
GO FAR.
WE WERE TO ALL APPLICANTS TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN
COMPLETING VARIOUS UNFAMILIAR
COMPONENTS LIKE FISCAL
SPONSORSHIP. A QUANTIFICATION OF
CARBON SEQUESTRATION VALUES FOR
PROJECTS AND OBTAINING
PERMISSION TO PROP UP PLANT
FORMS FROM CITIES LEARNING THE
SYSTEM. IS WHAT REALLY NEEDS TO
BE TAUGHT IN SOME OF THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE LEARN SOME THESE
COMMUNITIES.
AS A RESULT WE WERE ABLE TO
INCREASE THE PERCENTAGE OF
ELIGIBLE APPLICATIONS FROM FORTY
PERCENT TO EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT.
AND OF COURSE AFTER GRANT AWARD
WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT GRANTEES
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE PROJECT TO
COMPLETION.
A COUPLE EXAMPLES OF NEW
COMMUNITY GROUPS ARE WORKING
WITH OUR FATHERS AND FAMILY. OF
SAN JOAQUIN IN STOCKTON AS WELL
AS PARA PIONEERS IN SAN
FERNANDO.
LET ME GIVE YOU ANOTHER EXAMPLE
OF A ANOTHER PROJECT HAPPENING
AMIGO STILL LOS RIOS NO THIS IS
A MORE ESTABLISHED URBAN FORCE
GROUP. IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHO HAS AN INCREDIBLY AMBITIOUS
VISION OF THE EMERALD NECKLACE.
LINKING MORE THAN FIFTEEN
HUNDRED ACRES OF PARKS AND OPEN
SPACES ALONG THREE DIFFERENT
RIVERS AND LA.
AND EGOS IS DOING IT
METHODICALLY SEGMENT BY SEGMENT.
THE FUNDING THAT THEY RECEIVE
FROM CALIFORNIA RELIEF OF
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
PLANT.
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY TREES.
IS FOR THE WHITTIER NARROWS
PROJECT RUNNING ALONG TO THE
RIVERS AND TO MASSIVE FREEWAYS
WERE OTHERS OF SOME OF AMERICA'S
WORST AIR POLLUTION. AND THAT
SOME OF THE MOST POPULATED URBAN
AREAS IN THE UNITED STATES.
HAVING LOST TREES TO DRUM AND
BASS PASSED THE RESTORING THESE
TREES BY PARTING WITH HIGH
SCHOOL SERVICE CLUBS GIRL SCOUTS
SAN GABRIEL VALLEY CONSERVATION
CORPS.
ONE OF THE CONSERVATION CORPS.
YOUNG MEN ASSIGNED TO IT
RICARDO BART TO THE SECOND.
.
TOOK THE BUS AT SIX THIRTY AM
FROM HIS HOMEOWNERS WHO TO
CUMPLIR TREES HERE HE DROPPED
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL BUT LATER
GRADUATED WHILE WORKING ON
ANOTHER JOB CORPS PROGRAM. BUT
RICARDO EXPLAINED IT DIDN'T
REALLY LIKE SCHOOL WOULD RATHER
DO SOMETHING MORE PHYSICAL.
WORKING WITH PLANTS TREES IN
NATURE HELPED RICARDO TO FIND A
SENSE OF BELONGING HE HADN'T
FELT BEFORE HE SAID. AND
PLANTING ENTRIES IN BEING IN
NATURE EVEN URBAN NATURE HELPED
HIM DEAL WITH FRUSTRATION AND
ANGER. HIS NEW ATTITUDE WAS
REFLECTED IN HIS APPROACH TO
DIGGING IN DIRT THAT'S ROCK HARD
DUE TO DROUGHT IN. OUR CLIMATE
ARE EVERY CLIMATE HE SAID IT WAS
HARD AT FIRST BUT THEN YOU LEARN
HOW TO DO IT.
THEN YOU START TO ENJOY IT WHICH
IS A GREAT LIFE SKILL ANYWHERE.
THEM THIS LEADS US TO OUR LAST.
TOPIC WHICH IS JOBS.
AND.
WE HEARD OVER AND OVER AGAIN
THE TREES ARE WONDERFUL WHICH AS
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THESE
PROJECTS IN COMMUNITIES. AND THE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES WANT THE
TREES BUT THEY WANT JOBS.
AND SEVERAL OF THE EXISTING
URBAN FORCE PROJECTS ARE
PROVIDING WAGES PER EXAMPLE THE
URBAN CORE SAN DIEGO IS DOING
THAT IN PARTNERSHIP THE TO SAN
DIEGO SUSTAINABLE CLAREMONT HAS
THE GREEN CREW PROGRAM.
AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AT
EARTH TEAM AND MADERA COALITION
FOR COMMUNITY JUSTICE.
THOSE OUR NONPROFIT JOBS BASED
ON GRANTS.
IT'S MORE IMPORTANT HAVE STEADY
JOBS AND SO IT WAS IT WAS LIKE A
MARRIAGE MADE IN HEAVEN WHEN WE
HEARD THAT THE TREE CARE
INDUSTRY ISN'T HAVING A DIRE
SHORTAGE OF. OF TRIGGER WORKERS
AND THEY WERE WILLING TO EXPOSE
EXPAND THE LOTOF. TIME AND
EFFORT TO PROP PROVIDE TRAINING
FOR THIS.
SO WE ARE SUPPORTING A PROJECT
WITH LOCAL TREE CARE COMPANIES
MERRITT COLLEGE IN OAKLAND AS
WELL AS THE TREE CARE INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION TO DEVELOPMENT URBAN
ARBORIST CERTIFICATE PROGRAM.
AS WELL AS AN ASSOCIATE OF
SCIENCE CURRICULUM.
THAT PROVIDES A PATHWAY TO
STABLE GOOD PAYING JOBS.
AND THESE ARE THESE ARE JOBS
THAT WERE STABLE EVEN WHEN WE
HAVE THE RECESSION. AND THE
MINIMUM WAGE IN THE BAY AREA.
ANYWHERE FROM FIFTEEN TO
SEVENTEEN DOLLARS SO IT'S
IT SHOULD NOT THE MINIMUM WAGE
AND TING THE STARTING SALARY.
MUCH BETTER THAN THE MINIMUM
WAGE AT THIS POINT.
FROM THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
CURRICULUM SECTOR PARTNERSHIP
MODEL WILL SOON BE AVAILABLE TO
ALL INTERESTED CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO WE CAN
TAKE THIS MODEL IN USE AT
ANOTHER SPOT PURCHASED.
THE CITY WAS REALLY PART ABOUT
THIS IS THAT YOU HAD THE TREE
CARE COMPANIES INVOLVED AND
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT ARE GONNA
HIRE AND THEY WANTED TO BE THERE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE PROGRAM
WAS SET UP RIGHT SO THAT.
PEOPLE READY TO BE HIRED PRODUCT
ABOUT.
SO WE ALL KNOW THAT PLANTING
TREES IS GREAT AND OUR BEGINNING
TO PLANT JOBS AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY AND FOR YOUR INTEREST
IN THIS AS WELL AS YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN CAP AND TRADE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN GARCIA
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LINA VELASCO AND THE PLANNING
MANAGER FOR THE CITY OF RICHMOND
LOCATED IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA.
THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE LOCAL
PERSPECTIVE ON WHAT THE COLD.
BENEFITS OF URBAN GREENING AND
GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAMS
HAVE FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES LIKE RICHMOND.
RICHMOND IS A COMMUNITY OF
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE OUR POPULATIONS
MAJORITY PEOPLE OF COLOR. AND
THE CITY INCLUDE SEVERAL CENSUS
TRACTS THAT ARE WITHIN THE TOP.
TEN AND TWENTY PERCENT.
OF POLLUTION BURDEN COMMUNITIES
IN THE STATE ACCORDING TO CALLIN
VIRUS SCREEN THREE POINT NOW.
RICHMOND AS HAVE MANY
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ADOPTED A CLIMATE ACTION PLAN
AND IS CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS
OF. OF
UPDATING ITS GENERAL SAFETY
LOCAL HAZARD MITIGATION PLAN TO
CONSIDER CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS
ON OUR COMMUNITY. CAN IDENTIFY
MITIGATION AND MEASURES THAT THE
CITY CAN TAKE TO MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES MORE RESILIENT.
THE CLIMATE ACTION PLAN
IDENTIFIES FEASIBLE CITY AND
COMMUNITY ACTIONS THAT CAN COST
EFFECTIVELY REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AND IMPROVE
COMMUNITY HEALTH ACROSS SECTORS.
ONE OF THE KEY ACTIONS
IDENTIFIED IN OUR CLIMATE ACTION
PLAN.
TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES IS TO
EXPAND URBAN GREENING AND GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITY.
WHY GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE AND
URBAN GREENING? THE NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT IS BOTH IMPORTANT
FOR SEQUESTERING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND FOR MITIGATING THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE USES
VEGETATION SOILS AND NATURAL
PROCESSES TO MANAGE WATER. AND
IMPROVE THE NATURAL ENVIRONMENT.
THE CITY WILL REDUCE ITS
CONTRIBUTION TO CLIMATE CHANGE
POLICY ME TENUOUSLY PREPARING
FOR IMPACTS SUCH AS SEA LEVEL
RISE AND FLOODING.
GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE BENNETT'S
BENEFITS FLOOD CONTROL WATER
SUPPLY OF POLLUTION REDUCTION.
RECREATIONAL OPEN SPACE
URBAN AGRICULTURE AND URBAN
WILDLIFE HABITAT.
GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE URBAN
FORESTRY ALL WORK IN CONCERT
WITH THE NATURAL ENVIRONMENT TO
MAKE LOCAL LANDSCAPES.
MORE PRODUCTIVE AND PROVIDE
BENEFITS TO LOCAL RESIDENTS AND
ECOSYSTEMS.
IN THE FIRST ROUND OF URBAN
GREENING FINDINGS AWARDED IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO
PROJECTS OF RICHMOND RECEIVE
FUNDING.
THE RICHMOND WHILE THIS TRAIL
PHASE ONE. AND GREEN THE YELLOW
BRICK ROAD.
GRITTING THE YELLOW BRICK ROAD
WILL LEVERAGE A SIX POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM GRANT.
BY PLANTING APPROXIMATELY SIX
HUNDRED TREES.
AND INSTALLING APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY STORM WATER
PLANTERS BIAS WHEELS FILLED WITH
NATIVE PLANTS.
TO TRANSFORM A NEW BIKE
BOULEVARD.
INTO ONE OF THIS IN ONE OF THE
STATE'S MOST DISADVANTAGED
NEIGHBORHOODS.
THESE ONCE BARREN ENTRY LIST
STREETS WILL BE TRANSFORMED INTO
A LUSH GREEN VIBRANT AND HEALTHY
PUBLIC SPACES.
THE RICHMOND WHILE THIS TRIAL
PHASE ONE IS A ONE POINT ONE
MILE ADA ACCESSIBLE MULTIMODAL
MULTI BENEFIT GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE CORRIDOR. LOCATED
IN A PARK POOR. UNDERSERVED
NEIGHBORHOOD ENRICHMENT IT WILL
ENHANCE ACCESS TO URBAN GREEN
SPACES BY CREATING A NEW. SAFE
BICYCLE AND PEDESTRIAN PATHWAY
THAT WILL CONNECT DOWNTOWN
RICHMOND.
TO THE RICHMOND GREENWAY UNITY
PARK MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
PARK AND THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
TRAIL.
THE UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES OF
THE IRON TRIANGLE IN CORONADO
WILL BE ABLE TO SAFELY WALK OR
RIDE THEIR BICYCLES TO THESE
NEARBY URBAN GREEN SPACES.
WITHOUT FEAR OF BEING HIT BY A
CAR.
THESE PROJECTS ONE BELT ONCE
BELTS WILL RESULT IN GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSION REDUCTIONS IN
SEVERAL OTHER CO HEALTH BENEFITS
FOR RICHMOND RESIDENTS.
THESE INCLUDE IMPROVED AIR
QUALITY IMPROVED WATER QUALITY
IMPROVED ACCESS
TO OPEN SPACE.
AND WILL ENCOURAGE WALKING AND
BIKING REDUCING RISK OF OBESITY
RELATED ILLNESSES.
RICHMOND HAS THE PIT
CLIMATE CHANGE HAS HIGH
POTENTIAL IMPACTS IN RICHMOND
INCLUDING WILDFIRE RESTFUL
ADDRESS.
URBAN HEAT ISLAND EFFECT.
AND.
AS YOU KNOW MANY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES ARE MORE VULNERABLE
TO THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AND SO THESE PROJECTS WILL HELP
IMPROVE RESILIENCE IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
THE CITY IS URGING THE COMMITTEE
ON THE GOVERNOR TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE CAP AND TRADE FUNDING TO
THE URBAN GREETING CRAP PROGRAM.
SO THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
MUNICIPALITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE CAN IMPLEMENT PROJECTS
LIKE THE RICHMOND WELLNESS
TRAIL.
AND THE GREEN THE ELAPID CROWED
THIS PROGRAM AS ONE A FEW
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE THAT
SUPPORTS THE TOTAL CONVERSION OF
THE BUILT ENVIRONMENT.
INTO GREEN SPACE THAT IMPROVES
THE QUALITY OF LIFE OF OUR
RESIDENTS
THIS PROGRAM FUNDS BICYCLE AND
PEDESTRIAN IMPROVEMENTS.
AS WELL AS URBAN GREENING AND
GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE STATE HAS SEVERAL PROGRAMS
THAT WILL ONLY FIND ONE
COMPONENT OF THESE FOR EXAMPLE
THE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM WILL ONLY FUND THE
PEDESTRIAN THE BIKE
IMPROVEMENTS.
AND NOT FUN ANY TREE PLANTING OR
VEGETATION.
AND ONE OF THIS SINGLE MOST.
COMMENTS WE RECEIVE FROM OUR
RESIDENTS IS THAT YOU CAN'T JUST
BUILD THE BY CLEAN IT'S HOUSE TO
BE THE TOTAL CONVERSION BECAUSE
IT THE ST STILL DOESN'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE.
SO THIS ALLOWS THE CITY TO
IMPLEMENT A COMPLETE PROJECT
WITHOUT ASSEMBLING FUNDING FROM
VARIOUS SOURCES WHICH OFTEN
DELAYS THE DELIVERY OF PROJECTS
TO OUR RESIDENTS.
AND CAN ALSO BE ADMINISTRATIVELY
BERNARD SOME TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE ALREADY
IMPACTED BY INSUFFICIENT
STAFFING.
FOR URBAN GRITTY PROGRAM
CONNECTS LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
LARGER STATEWIDE CLIMATE CHANGE
POLICIES BY TRANSFORMING THE
BUILT ENVIRONMENT AND THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
IMPROVING COMMUNITY HEALTH.
URBAN GREENY AND GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS RESULTS
IN TANGIBLE IMPROVEMENTS TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND PROVIDE A
FORUM FOR RESIDENTS TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE. AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SUPPORTING
CLIMATE CHANGE ADAPTATION AND
MITIGATION MEASURES IN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
URBAN GREENING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE ARE IMPORTANT
COMPONENTS OF CLIENTS MIGHT
CITIES AND THEREBY SHOULD
RECEIVE FUNDING FROM THE STATE'S
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM.
RICHMOND IS A COMMUNITY THAT
DOESN'T JUST LIKE TO PLAN WE
LIKE TO IMPLEMENT AND WOOD LACK
WITHOUT FINDING WERE UNABLE TO
DO THAT GIVEN ARE CONSTRAINED
RESOURCES. AND SO WE ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO TO. HELP US
CONTINUE FUNDING FOR THESE
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. THINK YOU
JUST WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT THAT
I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE OF.
KNOWING SOME OF THE FOLKS IN THE
CITY OF RICH MEN AT GOING BACK
TO. SOME OF THE WORK BEING DONE
WITH CALIFORNIA I'M IN THE
HEALTH ELEMENT INCORPORATED TO
THE GENERAL PLAN. AND MORE
RECENTLY IN OUR. QUEST TO GET
THIS LEGISLATION US LIKE PARK
BOND ON THE BALLOT WE HAD OUR
ROUNDTABLE DISCUSSION OUT A
PUBLIC PARK.
AND GOT TO.
.
HERE AND LEARN ABOUT THE PROJECT
THAT YOU JUST HIGHLIGHTED SO
THANK YOU FOR UP.
CAN READ REAFFIRMING HOME
PORTENT VALUABLE IT IS THAT WE
GET OUT. OF THE CAPITAL AND DOES
YOU TRAVEL UP AND DOWN THE STATE
TO HEAR EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING ON
AS IT RELATES TO THE INVESTMENT
SAID THAT WE'RE MAKING. AND THEY
WERE ASKING TO BE MADE IN THE
LONG TERM SO
THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT SPEAKER.
I GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DEBORAH ONE
SCENE BLOOM I'M THE SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND RESEARCH
AT TREAT PEOPLE. IN CASE YOU'RE
NOT FAMILIAR WHICH HE PEOPLE WE
ARE AN ENVIRONMENTAL NONPROFIT
LOCATE IN LOS ANGELES. WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON URBAN FORESTRY
AND WATER POLICY ISSUES FOR OVER
FOUR DECADES NO. THANKS FOR
HAVING ME HERE.
SO TO THE POINT AT HAND JUST BY
THE ACTUAL PRESENCE OF THIS
COMMITTEE ON CLIMATE CHANGE IT'S
CLEAR THAT YOU'RE CLEAR THAT
WE'RE FACING EXTREME INTENSE
CLIMATE IMPACTS SOONER THAN WE
EXPECTED.
AND WE DON'T HOW TIME TO WASTE.
BUT THERE'S GOOD NEWS
TO GET THESE ANSWERS WE DO NOT
HAVE TO RECREATE THE WHEEL.
TREE PEOPLE HAS SPENT YEARS
STUDYING HOW AUSTRALIA HAS GONE
THROUGH SEVERAL OF ITS
EMERGENCIES SPECIFICALLY RELATED
TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
FOR INSTANCE HOW THEY SURVIVE
THEIR DEVASTATING TWELVE YEAR
MILLENNIUM DROUGHT AND HOW
THEY'RE GETTING THROUGH THEIR
CURRENT INCREASED HEAT PERIODS.
WE FOCUS ON AUSTRALIA BECAUSE
OUR TWO COUNTRIES ARE QUITE
SIMILAR IN ADDITION TO YOU
OBVIOUSLY OUR LIFESTYLE AND OUR
LANGUAGE. THE CITY IN MELBOURNE
FOR EXAMPLE HAS ABOUT FOUR
MILLION PEOPLE THE SAME AMOUNT
AS THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES IN IS
FACING THE SAME CLIMATE
CHALLENGES AS WE ARE.
DROUGHT
THE FLIPSIDE OF DROUGHT FLOODING
AND INTENSE HEAT
IN ADDITION THE CITY OF ADELAIDE
HAS THE SCHEMES.
MEDITERRANEAN TYPE OF CLIMATE
THAT MUCH OF CALIFORNIA HOUSE.
WE BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA CAN
AND SHOULD ADOPT AND THEN ADAPT
LESSONS FROM AUSTRALIA TO OUR
CURRENT SITUATION.
REGARDING URBAN FORESTRY IN
PARTICULAR.
WELL AUSTRALIA PROACTIVELY
DEPLOYED EMERGENCY TACTICS
DURING THEIR DROUGHT TO SEE
THEIR LARGE HERITAGE TREES VAST
AREAS OF LAND ENTRIES DIED
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRYSIDE.
IN THIS IS BECAUSE DURING THE
DROUGHT THE ROLLING MONTHS LEFT
AT ONE POINT OF WATER IN WHAT
THEY CALLED THEIR CATCHMENT BUT
WE COLOR WATERSHED. SO NO
IRRIGATION WAS ALLOWED.
WHEN NEED SAT BACK AND FINALLY
WERE ABLE TO EVALUATE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF WHAT HAPPENED.
THEY REALIZE THE HUGE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS THIS HOT ON THE ON THE
PEOPLE BOTH PSYCHOLOGICALLY AND
PHYSICALLY. IN FACT BASED ON
THAT WITHOUT THE ECOSYSTEM
SERVICES PROVIDED THROUGH THE
SHADE AND EVAPORATIVE COOLING OF
LEAFY TREE CANOPIES THE URBAN
HEAT ISLAND INTENSIFIED AND IN
FACT BECAME LETHAL.
FOR EXAMPLE IN JANUARY TWO
THOUSAND NINE MELVIN EXPERIENCED
IF SIXTY TWO PERCENT INCREASE IN
HEAT RELATED MORTALITY PROMPTING
THE ENTIRE CITY TO RETHINK OUR
THE WAY IT. AYE THAT WERE
IMPLEMENTED ITS DOUBT RICK
DROUGHT RESTRICTIONS.
THE AVERAGE TEMPERATURE NOW THEN
IN JANUARY IS SEVENTY DEGREES
FAHRENHEIT NOT. DISSIMILAR TO
MANY OF OUR CITIES HERE. DURING
THIS EXTREME HEAT EVENT IT WAS.
THE TEMPERATURES WERE EXCEEDING
A HUNDRED AND NINE DEGREES FOR
THREE CONSECUTIVE DAYS.
PUBLIC HEALTH RESEARCHERS
DETERMINE THE BEST WAY TO SAVE
LIVES LIVES IN TIMES OF EXTREME
HEAT. WAS TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE LIVED IN A COMMUNITY
WITH DENSE TREE CANOPY.
I IF YOU LOOK AT THE HANDOUTS
THAT I BELIEVE HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED TO YOU BY KATIE. ONE OF
THEM LOOKS LIKE THIS.
I. THE CITY MELTING CAME UP WITH
A STRATEGY OF FOUR PRONG
STRATEGY FIRST TO DOUBLE THEIR
TREE CANOPY COVER THIS WAS FROM
THERE TWENTY PERCENT TO FORTY
PERCENT.
TO TO INCREASE PERMEABILITY
THREE TO INCREASE GREENSPACE AND
FOR WAS TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT
OF STORM WATER HARVESTING.
ALL OF THIS WAS IN AN EFFORT.
NOT FOR THE CITY TO REDUCE I.
BEAT COOL THE CITY BY FOUR
DEGREES CENTIGRADE OR ABOUT
SEVEN DEGREES FAHRENHEIT.
SO HOW OF THE CHANGE GIVEN THEIR
EXPERIENCES
ONE THEY BEGAN TO SIGNIFICANTLY
INVEST IN KEEPING THEIR TREES
HEALTH BEING MAINTAINED IN THIS
EXAMPLE I JUST GAVE YOU THE CITY
CITY ALONE OF MOUNTAIN. INVESTED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OVER FIVE
YEARS A INTO THE FOUR STRATEGIES
I JUST MENTIONED.
SECOND THE CREATING NEW SOURCES
OF WATER STORMWATER CAPTURE IN
SOME CASES THEY WENT AS FAR AS
TAPPING INTO STORES TREATING THE
WATER AND THEN USING THAT TO
MAINTAIN THEIR TREES. AND THEY
CHANGE THEIR LAWS POLICIES IN
AND SENTENCED TO TAKE.
TO HELP THE URBAN FOREST DRIVE
AND TAKE AN AGGRESSIVE STANCE
AGAINST THEIR NEW HARSH CLIMATE
REALITY.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE TO LOOK ACROSS
THE OCEAN TO LEARN THESE LESSONS
WE CAN LEARN BECOME LOOK IN OUR
OWN BACKYARD.
I TREAT PEOPLE WE ARE NOW
LEADING A NATIONAL COLLABORATIVE
ON URBAN COOLING WITH YALE UCLA
AND SEVERAL OTHERS. AND RIGHT
NOW WE'RE MODELING AT THE COUNTY
OF LA THE OPTIMAL PRESCRIPTION
THE COMBINATION OF VEGETATION
INCLUDING TREES AND REFLECTIVE
SURFACES. TO DECREASE HUMAN
MORTALITY IN TIMES OF EXTREME
HEAT.
SOME GONNA GIVE YOU JUST A FEW
INITIAL RESULTS.
THE FIRST IS UNFORTUNATELY LA'S
UNIQUE DISTINCTION BUT SAID WE
HAVE A GREATER NUMBER OF WINTER
DAYS ABOVE NINETY DEGREES THAN
ANY OTHER REGION IN THE COUNTRY.
THIS MEANS THAT WE OCCASIONALLY
HAVE HEAT RELATED DEATHS
EVEN IN THE WINTER.
SECOND ME MORTALITY INCREASES
FIVE TIMES FROM THE FIRST TO THE
FIFTH. CONSECUTIVE DAY.
AND THE AFTER THE FIFTH DAY
MORTALITY RISK OF A IN LOS
ANGELES INCREASES FORTY SIX
PERCENT HISPANIC COMMUNITIES AND
FORTY EIGHT PERCENT AN ELDERLY
BLACK COMMUNITIES.
WHAT CAN WE DO ABOUT THIS
STUDIES ARE SHOWING THAT ANY
INCREASE COMBINATION THAT THEIR
MODELING OF INCREASED?
TREES AND VEGETATION AND OUR
REFLECTIVITY RESULTS IN AT LEAST
DOUBLE DIGIT PERCENTAGE
DECREASES AND HE WON MORTALITY
SO THERE ARE ANSWERS OUT THERE.
LAST YEAR LIKE TO SHIFT YOUR
COUPLE LOCAL EXAMPLES OF WHAT A
TREE PLANTINGS ARE DOING IN OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES BY LOCAL I
MEAN LOS ANGELES BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT WE ARE BASED.
FIRST AS PART OF OUR SCHOOL
GREENING INITIATIVE SHE PEOPLE
RECEIVED HELLFIRE FUNDING TO DO
SOME GREAT WORK AT CHATSWORTH
PARK ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
ONE OF OUR STAFFERS GUY WORK
WITH THE GREEN TEAM OF PARENTS
AND TEACHERS REMOVED CONCRETE
PLANTED TWENTY FOUR TREES ON THE
PLAYGROUND THEY CREATED A
READING GROW FOR THE KIDS.
THE KIDS ARE REALLY TAKING
OWNERSHIP OF THESE TREES THEY
WATER THEM. BUT THE REAL ISSUE
IS THAT IT'S NOW PROVIDING THE
KIDS WITH A RESPITE FROM THE
WIND AND THE HEAT IN THIS VERY
HOT AND WINDY AREA.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE OTHER HANDOUT
I'VE PROVIDED HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE
IT.
WHAT THIS SHOWS IS A TYPICAL
STREET ON A VERY COOL DAY AT
SEVENTY THREE DEGREES ON THIS
DAY? ON BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
PICTURE ON THE RIGHT WITH A
SPECIAL INFRARED CAMERA. IT
SHOWS YOU THAT THE UNSHADED
SIDEWALK IS A HUNDRED AND SEVEN
DEGREES.
THE SHEET INSIDE WHAT HOWEVER IS
EIGHTY TWO DEGREES SO THAT TREED
MADE A TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
DEGREE DIFFERENCE FOR THE
PEDESTRIAN EXPERIENCE.
THE LAST EXAMPLE IS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S GOING TO TREAT
PEOPLE WITH FUNDS TO PLAN
FOURTEEN HUNDRED TREES AND
PARKWAYS IN. A COMMERCIAL
QUARTERS AND HUNTING TO PARKING
CUT A HATE THROUGH MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY.
THESE PLANTINGS ARE GOING TO
INCLUDE IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND BUILD HEALTHIER COMMUNITIES
THROUGH HEAT REDUCING SHADING
CLEANER AIR.
SO OF COURSE IN ADDITION TO
INCREASING THE URBAN TREE CANOPY
BY FOURTEEN HUNDRED TREES IT'S
GOING TO CREATE LOCAL JOBS. AND
INSPIRE RESIDENTS TO CHANGE
THEIR BEHAVIOR HOW WILL IT DO
THIS.
BECAUSE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
EDUCATION ARE EXTREMELY VITAL
COMPONENTS TO THIS WORK.
FOR EXAMPLE VOLUNTEERS IN THE
COMMUNITY ARE RECRUITED DIRECTLY
BY REGIONAL MANAGER AT HIGH
SCHOOLS CHURCHES COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS.
OUT RESIDENTS ON EACH STREET
WHERE THERE'S GOING TO BE
PLANTINGS ARE PARTICIPATING. AND
EVERY VOLUNTEER WORK DAY BEGINS
WITH A TREE CARE AYE TRAINING.
ALSO EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS ARE
DISTRIBUTED TO OTHER HOMES NOT
INVOLVED SO THEY CAN UNDERSTAND
THE BENEFITS OF TREES.
WE CHOSE THESE COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE OF THE HIGH POPULATION
DENSITY OF EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND%
RESIDENTS IN JUST OVER FOUR
SQUARE MILES. IS COMMUNITIES
TRADITIONALLY HAVE A LACK OF AIR
CONDITIONING.
LOW TREE CANOPY IN OTHER WAYS
TO COMBAT THE EXTREME HEAT.
MODELING SUGGEST THAT BOTH IN
HUNTINGTON PARK CUT HAY COULD
HAVE THREE TO FOUR TIMES THE D.
NONE NUMBER OF DAYS WITH
TEMPERATURES OVER NINETY FIVE
DEGREES AND AS LITTLE AS. TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AND OF COURSE AIR
QUALITY IS ALSO A CHALLENGE.
AND THIS IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF
ONE COMMUNITY. THEIR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR IDENTIFIED
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN LOS
ANGELES AND VENTURA COUNTY
ALONE.
HUGE PARTS OF OUR POPULATION ARE
AT RISK
SO IN CLOSING WE ASKED THE
LEGISLATURE SHE CAN. SHOULD
INVEST IN URBAN FORESTRY NOW DO
AS MANY FUNDING VEHICLES AS
POSSIBLE THIS SHOULD BE AMONGST
OUR HIGHEST PRIORITY TO PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHARTER CO SENATE
RISE OF STAFF.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME. I'M
EAGER ELECTION I'M YOUR UNIVERSE
CALIFORNIA COOPERATIVE EXTENSION
ADVISER BASED OUT OF SAM
ACCOUNTS AND CISCO COUNTIES.
AND I HELP
BERMAN CREE MANAGERS.
DO THEIR JOB SUSTAINABLY.
AS WELL AS OUR COMMUTE BENEFIT
ORGANIZATIONS
WITH THEIR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
SO OFTEN SOME A LITTLE DIFFERENT
BUT I THOUGHT I WOULD JUST TRY
TO WRAP UP BY KIND OF
SUMMARIZING THE THREE KINDS OF
BENEFITS WE DERIVE FROM URBAN
TREES.
.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S KIND
OF UNIQUE TO URBAN TREES SECOND
THINK OF IT.
CAN THINK OF A FIRST CATEGORY
THE BENEFIT THAT TREES PROVIDE
TO OTHER LIVING THINGS YOU KNOW
BIRDS BEES ALL OF THAT STUFF THE
ECOLOGICAL SIDE OF THINGS.
THE SECOND KIND OF BENEFITS
WOULD BE THE ECOSYSTEM SERVICES.
AND THAT WAS MENTIONED QUITE A
BIT ORANGE TODAY THOSE ARE ALL
THE THINGS THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
HAVE TO PAY FOR.
SO IF A TREE SHADE YOUR HOUSE
AND YOU DON'T OF THROWING
RECOGNITION AS MUCH.
THAT'S AN ECOSYSTEM SERVICE.
AND UNIVERSITY RESEARCH OVER THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS HAS REALLY
QUANTIFY THAT SO.
WE ALWAYS KNEW THAT IT WAS NICE
TO HAVE A TREE SHEDDING THEIR
HOUSE.
BUT STARTING ABOUT TWENTY YEARS
AGO WE WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO PUT A
NUMBER ON IT.
SO THAT AND IN FACT YOUR
BACKGROUND DOCUMENT SUMMARIZES
THAT VERY NICELY THE BENEFITS OF
THOSE ECOSYSTEM SERVICES.
OUR SUMMER AROUND EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR IN CALIFORNIA.
NOW.
THE THIRD KIND OF TRUE BENEFITS
I THINK THIS IS THE MOST
EXCITING PART AND I'M GLAD CINDY
MENTIONED. MENTION THEM RD
HEALTH BENEFITS.
AND THIS IS REALLY RECENT
UNIVERSITY RESEARCH GOING BACK
ONLY ABOUT SEVEN OR EIGHT YEARS.
THAT HAS BEEN ABLE TO QUANTIFY.
EFFECTS ON HUMAN HEALTH AND
AGAIN IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT I
DON'T THINK THIS IS SURPRISING
TO ANYBODY TO SAY THAT.
PEOPLE IN.
NEIGHBORHOODS IN MORE TREES TEND
TO BE HEALTHIER DESERVE JUST
NICER PLACES TO LIVE. BUT REALLY
QUANTIFYING THOSE EFFECTS OF
BEEN DIFFICULT.
GOING BACK TO ABOUT THE EARLY
TWO THOUSANDS
WE NOW HAVE NUMBERS THAT SHOW.
REDUCTION IN CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASE THAT SHOW REDUCTION IN.
OF LOW BIRTH WEIGHT INFANTS
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT REDUCTION
WOULD JUST THE TEN PERCENT
INCREASE INCREASE COVER WHICH IS
REALLY QUITE AMAZING THERE'S
RENDON THESE ARE VERY CAREFULLY
DONE STUDIES THAT.
I FIND DIFFICULT THREE BUT
THEY'RE THEY'RE.
AND ONE OF THE MOST RECENT
STUDIES COMES FROM BRITAIN AND
IT.
DEALS WITH MENTAL HEALTH
SO WE KNOW THAT.
RICH PEOPLE ON THE WHOLE ARE
GENERALLY HEALTHIER THAN.
POOR PEOPLE RIGHT.
BUT.
WHERE PEOPLE HAVE BETTER ACCESS
TO URBAN TREES IN URBAN
GREENSPACE THAT DISPARITY
NARROWS AND IN FACT IT'S A FORTY
PERCENT DIFFERENCE IN
DISPARITIES? SO GIVEN THAT.
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH INTERVENTIONS
ARE OFTEN VERY LIMITED AND GIVEN
THAT WE. HAVE THE. ECONOMIC
DISPARITIES WE HAVE IN MANY OF
OUR COMMUNITIES. TREES REPRESENT
THIS IDEA OF AN EQUITY GENIC
ENVIRONMENT SOMETHING THAT CAN
BE DONE TO REDUCE
THE DISPARITIES IN HEALTH
OUTCOMES.
NOW TO ACHIEVE ALL THIS.
OF WE HAVE TO NOT ONLY PLANT
TREES BUT MAKE SURE THOSE TREES
SURVIVE AND THIS IS WHERE MY
COLLEAGUES FROM MARISSA
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT.
TEND TO BE GOING AFTER OUT TREES
ESPECIALLY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THOSE ARE DE
INVASIVE FRAUD HOLE BORERS AND
SOME.
RELATIVELY RECENT TREAT DISEASES
UP AND IT'S CERTAIN IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT THE TREE CANOPY WE
SEE TODAY.
IS THE RESULT OF PAST MANAGEMENT
SO IF YOU WALK.
THROUGH.
DOWNTOWN AND MIDTOWN SACRAMENTO
YOU'RE REALLY SEEING THE EFFORTS
OF URBAN FORESTERS FROM A LONG
TIME AGO.
SO. IT'S REALLY QUITE IMPORTANT
THAT WE NOT ONLY CONTINUE
PLANTING TREES BUT CONTINUE
FINDING WAYS TO INTEGRATE THEM
INTO OUR INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO THE FACT TWENTY THIRTY FIFTY
YEARS FROM NOW UP PEOPLE COME
AFTER US CONCEDED THIS WAS THIS
WAS A GOOD IDEA.
AND I'M I'M ESPECIALLY MY OWN
RESEARCH IS A SPECIAL INTERESTS
THAT IN AND.
UP TREAT THIS SERVICES NAMELY
WHAT HAPPENS WITH TREES FAILING
HOW WE CAN REDUCE THAT.
TREAT FAILURE BUT ALSO HOW WE
TRANSITION INTO THIS REALLY
ENVISIONED INFRASTRUCTURE ABOUT
MARRYING MENTION WHERE WE USE AT
LEAST THREE NEW SOURCES OF WATER
GRAY WATER RECYCLED WATER AND
STORING WATER. TO SUPPLY WATER
NEEDS OF TREES. SO.
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS MORE
COMPLEX IN OUR URBAN
FOREST AND THAT'S OKAY.
BECAUSE THEY WILL ALSO GET MORE
SUSTAINABLE AND BETTER
PERFORMING OVERALL. SO.
YOU HAVE EXPECT QUESTIONS THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME THINK YOU.
THANK YOU AND.
AS AS I WORK APPEAR I'M ALWAYS
THINKIN ABOUT YOU KNOW I THINK
GENERALLY THE LEGISLATURE'S
ALWAYS WORK IN WAYS THAT.
STRENGTH IN THE FABRIC OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WHETHER IT BE
THROUGH FOR HOUSING OR HEALTH
CARE FOR BETTER SCHOOLS.
DENIES AS I LOOK BACK THINKING
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE WE'VE
ACCOMPLISHED WE'VE ALWAYS PUT
SOME KIND OF THE YOU KNOW WATER
BOND WE HAVE SOME KIND OF
ENVIRONMENTAL.
ASPECT TO THE WATER BOND THAT
COVERS A.
CAPTURING MORE GREEN SPACE
ACROSS THE STATE IN PRESERVING
AND FOR FUTURE YEARS.
I IN MY DISTRICT AYE AYE AYE
LARGELY SERVE.
A LOWER INCOME DISTRICT.
YOU KNOW GENERALLY.
.
I DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES BUT
EVEN IN THOSE AREAS PEOPLE WANNA
SEE MORE LAND PRESERVE.
FOR OUR OPEN SPACE.
AND AND.
YOU KNOW WHAT WERE WERE
DEFINITELY.
WORKING ON THAT THROUGH OUR
WATER BOND TO PARKS BOND THAT
WAS PUTTING FORWARD I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE A GREAT.
A GREAT PROGRAM ABOUT GENERAL
ACROSS THE STATE.
AND AS WE DO THAT WERE WERE
PUTTING AN EMPHASIS ON
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IT IS
ALWAYS.
WRITTEN INTO ANY KIND OF
INITIATIVE THAT WE WORK ON.
IN ANY AREA OF OF WHETHER IT BE
EDUCATION OR ALL THOSE AREAS
HAVE MEANT A MENTION.
I'M WORKING ON A BILL RICK
REGARDLESS PROMISE OWNS AND AND
AND NEW.
THE I KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IS WORKING ON.
OUR OPPORTUNITIES OWNS A NEW
PROGRAM OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS GONNA HELP
REIMBURSEMENT UNDERSERVED AREAS.
AND WE'RE WORKING ON ON MAKING
THAT HAPPEN.
AND AND IT IT'S.
YOU KNOW I'D LIKE TO SEE.
A LESS MONEY BEING SPENT ON.
ON ON ON REPEATING KIND OF THE
SAME.
HA OR OR OR JUST
FINDING WAYS TO NAVIGATE WITH
BUREAUCRACY BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A
LOT OF LEVELS OF BUREAUCRACY OUR
STATE OFTENTIMES.
THE PEOPLE ARE LOOKING FOR
RESOURCES GET GET CAUGHT UP IN
LIKE WHO'S WHO WHOSE PER WHO'S
ADMINISTERING THIS PROGRAM
VERSES THAT PROGRAM. AND IF YOU
WANT TO DO SOME KIND OF
NEIGHBORHOOD REINVESTMENT EFFORT
WHO YOU GO TO THEM YOU HAVE TO
GO TO HARD FOR SOME FUNDS YOU
HAVE TO GO TO. ENERGY COMMISSION
FOR GRANTS WHICH HE GETS ITS IT
GETS VERY COMPLICATED AND A NICE
TO SEE.
THAT THERE BE A SOME.
I KNOW THIS OFTEN FIND FALLS ON
THE LOCALS TO SAY LET'S.
COME UP WITH THE LOCAL ICE
PROGRAM.
AND AND AS I AND I PUSH A BILL
THAT TRIES TO WORK LOCALS TO SAY
LET'S LET'S PRIORITIZE FUNDING
IN AREAS WHERE WE WANT TO SEE.
KIND OF THE THE THE.
THE MOST UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
GET UP NOW.
ADEQUATE SHARE OF RESOURCES.
HOW DO WE DO ABOOT DO BETTER JOB
OF THAT I MEAN?
I MEAN IS THE STATE.
TENDS TO BE A DAUNTING PLACE TO
FOR FOR LOCAL LOOK AT AND SAY
HOW DO WE.
PARTNER WHAT THE STATE WITHOUT
HAVING TO GO SPEND THE MAJORITY
OF OUR TIME NAVIGATING.
THE BUREAUCRACY WE WANT WE WANT
TO HEAR MARK THIS MONEY. WE
WANNA GOOD TO GO TO THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. IT'S OFTEN HARDER
TO INVEST MONEY THAT UNDERSERVED
AREAS BECAUSE THERE ISN'T ENOUGH
FIRST.
RIGHT THERE ISN'T A WAY TO
SUSTAIN IF WE PLANT TREES WHO'S
GOING TO WATER THEM WHO'S GOING
TO TAKE CARE OF THEM.
AND OFTEN TIMES THERE ARE.
ONE OF THE SPEAKERS MENTION
URBAN CORE.
THEY'RE THE ONES HE OFTEN GO AND
PLANTED TREES AND SOMETIMES TAKE
CARE OF THEM BUT THEY NEED A
FUNDING SOURCE IF WE PROVIDE
THAT FUNDING SOURCE.
IF WE PROVIDE MATCHING MONEY TO
OUR PARKS PUNK HOW CAN WE DO
BETTER. HOW CAN WE?
?
DO A BETTER DELIVERY OF OF OF.
SERVICE A FUNDING.
AND AND EVERYTHING AS A WHOLE TO
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
DON'T THE LIMITED RESOURCES THAT
WE HAVE REALLY GOING TO THESE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND MAKE THE TAKE
MAKE.
THE BIGGEST BANG FOR THE BUCK
DOES ANYONE HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
SHAUNA. YES AND I'M ACTUALLY SO
GLAD YOU RAISED THAT.
NINETY TWO PERCENT OF THESE
FUNDS WENT INTO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES BUT THERE ARE MANY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE THAT EITHER DIDN'T
KNOW ABOUT THE PROGRAM.
DO COULDN'T TAKE ON THE
REIMBURSEMENT AYE RESPONSIBILITY
IS.
THE LIABILITY I DIDN'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY SHIRLEY RIGHT THERE
GRANTED THERE SO MANY BARRIERS
TO APPLICATION FOR UNDERSTOOD
RESOURCE COMMUNITIES.
IT'S NOT IN THIS PROGRAM BUT I
WE ARE SPONSORING A BELL WITH
SOME PARTNERS I'M IN THE
AUDIENCE RIGHT NOW GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE.
SENATE BILL TEN SEVENTY TWO
THAT IS ABOUT BUILDING REGIONAL
CAPACITY
AND IT'S ABOUT GIVING FUNDING TO
REGIONS SO THAT THEY CAN BUILD
THEIR OWN CAPACITY. THIS TAKES
PLANNING THE STATE'S ACTUAL
STAFF THIS TAKES A BUDGET SERVER
CONSULTANT SUPPORT TO HELP WITH
THE GREENHOUSE GAS
QUANTIFICATION THAN OTHER
TECHNICAL P. SAYS. THEY'RE ALL
OF THESE AYE CAPACITY THAT IT
TAKES TO ACTUALLY COMPETE FOR
STATE FUNDS IT NOT ENOUGH RIGHT
I THINK YOUR POINT IS IS RIGHT
ON POINT IN TERMS OF IT'S NOT
ENOUGH TO DESIGNATE DESIGNATE
FUNDS TO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY AND ESSENTIAL
WE ALSO NOW HAVE TO GO IN AND
MAKE SURE WE'RE INCREASING THE
CAPACITY OF LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
BE ABLE TO ACCESS AND COMPETE
FOR FUNDS. AND THEN ON THE OTHER
SIDE WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THE
STATE HAS SUFFICIENT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND STREAMLINING AND
ALIGNING THEIR PROGRAM
GUIDELINES AND APPLICATION
TIMELINES AND REQUIREMENTS.
I'M SO I THINK THERE'S THE ROLE
OF WORKING WITH COMMUNITIES ON
THE GROUND AND REALLY INCREASING
THAT CAPACITY AND THE ROLE OF
STREAMLINING AND MAKING SURE OUR
STATE PROCESSES ARE AS.
YOU'RE NOW STREAMLINED AND USER
FRIENDLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND SO AGAIN NOT WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT BUT THERE WE ARE WORKING
ON A BILL THAT WOULD DO SOME OF
THAT BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND. AND
DOING THINGS THE WAY WE'VE DONE
THEM PASSED MEAN THAT MONEY WILL
CONTINUE TO GO TO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO APPLY FOR THEM
VERSES ALL THE OTHER COMMUNITIES
THAT NEED THE MONEY JUST AS BAD
IF NOT WORSE.
AND.
THAT'S THAT'S WONDERFUL TO HEAR
THAT I WANT TO LOOK OUT FOR THAT
BILL SEE HOW WE CAN SUPPORT IT
LOOK AT IT TO MAKE SURE IT'S IT
ACCOMPLISHES SCHOOL. AND ALSO
YOU KNOW I REPRESENT.
IN CALIFORNIA SOME OF THE.
CITIES WITH THE WORST AIR
QUALITY IN THE NATION.
YOU KNOW ON SENDING WILL COUNTY
ONE OF THE WORSE IS PARTY LOGAN
BECAUSE OF THE PORT. EMISSIONS
AND DOES.
NEIGHBORHOODS ALSO TEND TO BE
PARK DEFICIENT.
TREAT EFFICIENT.
AND.
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO.
CRITICS THEY PROGRAM HERE THAT
REALLY TARGETS PUTTING TREES IN
THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS.
EL CENTRO IS ANOTHER ONE CUT
CALEXICO IN AGAIN.
I GO TO THOSE.
NEIGHBORHOODS AS WELL AND THE
VERY TREE DEFICIENT.
AND THEY ALSO TEND TO HAVE OTHER
PARTICULATE MATTER THERE. THAT
COME FROM AGRICULTURE SO THOSE
ARE ALL THE CHALLENGES EIGHT THE
DEAL BUT THEY WOULD NICE. TO IT
WOULD BE NICE TO SEE.
US ARE TO OUR OUR PRIORITIZATION
PROCESS OF FUNDS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE WE TARGET THOSE FUNDS
FOR COMMUNITIES.
THAT HAVE REALLY POOR AIR
QUALITY WILL WE HAVE A HIGH
ASTHMA RATES.
AND WERE.
ALTHOUGH WE'RE DEALING WITH SOME
OF SOLUTIONS OF. ONE OF THE
CAUSES OF THAT PICKED PARTICULAR
MATTER IN THOSE COMMUNITIES.
THAT THAT COULD BE.
ONE OF THAT THE REMEDIES TO
HELP US ACCOMPLISH ON THE TREES.
AND I'D LOVE TO SEE HOW WE CAN.
WORK TO DEVELOP MORE.
HERE BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS WERE INFORMATIVE.
AND ALSO VERY ENCOURAGING I HAD
NO IDEA WHERE INVESTING THIS
MONEY MATURE TREES.
I WAS A LOCAL COUNCIL MEMBERS
AND YOU KNOW WE WE HAD A VERY
AGGRESSIVE LOCAL PROGRAM.
I PLANNING TREES OUT THERE AND.
.
I I'VE ALWAYS. BEEN EXTREMELY
OPPOSED PROJECTS THAT.
SOMEHOW HAVE THAT THAT THAT THE.
THE EFFECT OF REMOVING TREES
FROM THE ENVIRONMENT WE GOTTA.
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE.
IT INTO IN IN DOING NEW
PROJECTS AND AND PROPOSING
FUTURE PROJECTS THAT THEY
INCORPORATE INCORPORATE GREEN
AREAS ESPECIALLY THOSE
UNDERSERVED AREA SO.
THIS WAS VERY FORMATIVE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
PLEASE. ONE ATTACK ON.
I JUST HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL
COMMENT ENTRIES ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR ALL THESE REASONS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
FIRST BUFFERING FOR POLLUTION
ETCETERA. AND I THINK THE OTHER
THING THAT WE NEED TO LEARN FROM
IS IS THE DROUGHT THAT WE HAD A
COUPLE YEARS AGO. AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE.
GET THE MESSAGE OUT RIGHT AWAY
THAT WHEN WE SAY TURN OFF THE
WATER TO THE LONG WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE TREES AND THAT
WE HAVE INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS WE
SHOULD TAKE ADVANTAGE OF HAVING
SILICON VALLEY IN THE STATE TO
HAVE. NEW HIGH TECH WAYS OF
TAKING CARE OF WATER INTO THE
AWARDING ENOUGH AND NOT TOO MUCH
AND IT'S NOT RUNNING DOWN THE
DRAIN. BUT WE NEED TO HAVE MORE
SOLUTIONS THAT LEVERAGE HOW ONLY
MAINTAINING THESE TREES IN THIS.
ARID ENVIRONMENT IF WE'RE GONNA
LIVE HERE.
THANK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH MY QUESTION IS I
MEAN KNOW IF THERE'S A BALLPARK.
FIGURE A NUMBER RIGHT THAT THAT
WE'VE ESTIMATED.
TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE THE
IMMEDIATE NEED TODAY I MEAN YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT.
AND THE. AMOUNT OF GRANTS THAT
WERE AWARDED VERSUS THE AMOUNT
OF APPLICATIONS THAT CAME IN.
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT THAT THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION ISN'T.
EVEN CLOSE TO WHAT I THINK WE
ESTIMATE IS NEEDED DOES ANYONE
HAVE ANY OF.
IDEA WHAT THAT BALLPARK FIGURE
MAY LOOK LIKE.
WELL.
THE URBAN FORESTRY PROGRAM WAS
OVER SUBSCRIBE BY FOUR HUNDRED
PERCENT.
SO AND AND YOU YOU ALSO NEED TO
KNOW THAT THEIR BEEN FORCED TO
PROGRAM I THINK IS ONE OF THE
SMALLEST OF THE.
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAMS.
WHERE THE SECOND SMALLEST?
SO WERE I HAD TO MAKE A BAD PUN
BUT WE DO IT ALL TIME WHERE DROP
IN THE BUCKET AS FAR AS. THE
SHORES WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE
BUDGET AND WE COULD DO A LOT
MORE IF THAT AMOUNT WERE.
TRIPLED.
THEN IT'S WHY I MENTION RIGHT
THAT THE.
MONEY IN THE PAST PROPOSITION
SIXTY EIGHT.
AND WASN'T TOO REPLACE WHAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS AND I WANNA.
AND CONTINUE TO HIT THAT HARD IN
TERMS OF. GETTING COLLECTIVE
SUPPORT.
AS THE BUDGET CONVERSATIONS ARE
TAKING PLACE.
INSULT YOUR HELP AND SUPPORT ON
THAT WOULD BE VERY CRITICAL TO
GETTING THAT MESSAGE ACROSS.
IT CENTER BUT IF I CAN ALSO ADD
SOME COMMENTS.
.
AND I'LL A HISTORICALLY WHEN THE
FIRST EUROPEANS CAME CALIFORNIA.
THERE WERE THERE WERE.
PINE.
TREFOREST AS FAR AS THE MIDDLE
PENINSULA OF BAJA CALIFORNIA.
AND. YOU KNOW THE WE WERE I
REPRESENT SAN DIEGO WHICH IS
FAMOUS FOR
TORY PINE WHICH IS KIND OF THE
THE ONLY ONE OF ITS KIND
COASTAL.
PINE TREE THAT. IS THREATENED.
AND THE FIRES THAT WE'VE HAD OUT
THERE IN JULIAN FOR EXAMPLE HAVE
DECIMATED. OR PINE.
WOULD FORCE OUT THERE WERE
SCIENTISTS PREDICT IT'LL NEVER
REGENERATE.
THE LAST DROUGHT HAS CAUSED.
THIS INFESTATION OF BEETLE IN
THE PINE TREES UP THERE IN THE
MOUNTAINS.
THAT HAVE AFFECTED NOT THOUSANDS
OF TREES MILLIONS OF TREES.
AND AS MANY AS WERE PLANTED.
WE REALLY CAN'T BACK FILL THE
MUCH THAT HAS.
BEEN LOST THROUGH THIS DROUGHT
AND NATURAL FIRE. PROCESS THAT
IS REALLY DEVASTATING THE AMOUNT
OF TREES IN OUR STATE.
I MEAN DOES NOT FOR LONG IS
BEING ERODED ALMOST LIKE A
CANCER ACROSS THE STATE GOING UP
THIS FAR NORTH.
SHASTA COUNTY WE SAW THE FIRES
LA COUNTY NAPA THAT THIS IS
THIS.
I MEAN.
IN THE END YOU KNOW IN IN YOUR
PRESENTATION VERY LITTLE WAS
MENTIONED ABOUT.
THE DEVASTATION OUR FORESTS AND
HOW THAT IS IS IS HAVING AN
IMPACT ON OUR QUALITY ACROSS THE
STATE.
WAY BEYOND JUST THOSE AREAS THAT
ARE A CHALLENGE BY REGULAR.
YOU KNOW A LOCALIZED EMISSIONS
SUTTER CREEK POOR AIR QUALITY.
I MEAN WHY HOW MUCH. OF THIS
PROGRAM IS ACTUALLY MAKING.
A DENT IN FIVE
AT LEAST BACK FEELING WHAT WAS
LOST IN TWO WE KNOW.
PERCENTAGE WISE.
YEAH AND TERMS OF QUANTITY OF
OF.
TREES LOST IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS.
AND WHAT WE'VE DONE IT TRYING TO
RESTORE THAT EVEN IF IT'S DONE
AT A LOCAL LEVEL NOT URBAN I
SAID HE'D. I KNOW.
.
KILL FIRE WAS HERE AND.
APPRECIATED THE COMMENTS BY MR.
HANG BUT.
.
DEWEY DO WE HAVE A OF FIGURE
TERMS OF.
.
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT FOR SOME
TO SAY MEASURE CERTAIN QUANTITY
THE QUANTITY OF TREASON IN JUST.
I KNOW WE CAN'T.
THE CHALLENGE. I MEAN MEASURING
SEQUESTRATION INSULAR CARBON
SEQUESTRATION DIFFERENT.
I'M THE SAME QUANTITY OF TREES
WILL LIMIT WHAT ARE WE LOOKING
AT OUR STATE IN TERMS OF LOSSES.
VERSES GAINES.
THE UPPER I COULD VOLUNTEER
ANNOUNCER TWO TO ONE PART OF THE
EQUATION.
WE HAVE TWO DATES
THE OUR BEST ESTIMATE IS A
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE MILLION
TREES ARE. ARE DEAD THE THREE
SOLD THE TEAM ONCOLOGY AND AND
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IN THE SENSE THAT SOME
ARTIFICIAL DISTINCTION BETWEEN.
URBAN TREES AND.
TREES IN IN THE FOREST.
AB DID THEIR OLD TREES AND
THEY'LL DIE FROM THE SAME
DISEASES.
.
WE DON'T HAVE.
AND ESTIMATE OF THE NUMBER OF
TREES IN TOTAL.
AT LEAST I DON'T HAVE AT MY
FINGERTIPS.
BUT I THINK PART OF THE EQUATION
WITH.
TREE MORTALITY ISSUE IS NOT SO
MUCH.
TRY TO REPLANT EVERY TREE THAT
DIED. BUT RATHER FOCUSING ON.
MANAGEMENT'S
OF FOREST THAT MAKES TO TREES
MORE RESILIENT.
THAT MAY JUST MEAN.
FEWER TREES PER ACRE BUT THE
ONES THAT ARE LEFT.
ARE. MORE ARE ARE BETTER ABLE TO
UTILIZE TO TOTAL AMOUNT THE
NUTRIENTS ON WATER ON THE SITE
AND ARE MORE LIKELY TO SURVIVE.
AND AYE I THINK IGOR COULD
EXPAND ON THIS AS WELL.
BUT.
THANK YOU HELL YEAH I I WAS
GOING TO SUGGEST THAT IT IS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT ON THE SOME
OF THAT.
WITH PROPER MANAGEMENT BELIEVES
FOREST IN THE SIERRA. WILL
ULTIMATELY RECOVER TO SOMETHING
SO CERTAINLY. ACTIVE PLANTINGS
NEEDED AND AND THAT'S HOW YOU
POINTED OUT IT DOES FORCE MAY
NOT LOOK LIKE WOULD USE TO LOOK
LIKE. BUT THEY CAN STILL BE
HEALTHY PRODUCTIVE PROVIDE A
WHOLE SET OF BENEFITS AND. MANY
OF THOSE BENEFITS REALLY ARE
ECOLOGICAL RIGHT. HABITAT THEIR
THEIR BENEFITS TO OTHER.
LIVING ORGANISMS WHEREAS IN
CITIES WITHOUT.
CONTINUED ACTIVE MANAGEMENT
WITHOUT CONTINUED PLANTING WE
ARE. PRETTY MUCH GOING TO
CONTINUE ON A WRONG TRAJECTORY
WHICH IS THAT WE KEEP LOSING
CANOPY AND THAT'S THE SORT OF
BIG DIFFERENCE CONCEPTUALLY
BETWEEN.
NATURAL FORESTS IN OVER FORCE
ROOM FOR US REALLY BECOME AN
ACTIVE MANAGEMENT BY. PEOPLE
LOCAL.
CREE MANIFESTLY BENEFIT
ORGANIZATIONS UP.
NATURAL FOREST YOU KNOW YOU
COULD ACTUALLY REPLANT AND WALK
AWAY THAT'S NOT SOMETHING YOU
CAN DO IT IN AN URBAN FOREST.
THE OTHER THING TO KIND OF KEEP
IN MIND IS THAT. IN. METAPHORS
ARE SELDOM CONVERSION OF TYPE IN
OTHER WORDS SOMETHINGTHAT USED
TO BE A FOREST AGAIN WITH A
LITTLE BIT OF PROPER MANAGEMENT
IS LIKELY TO STAY A FOREST.
IN CITIES AND I THINK WE ALL
KNOW THIS INTUITIVELY ONCE THE
TREES REMOVED THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE IT'S GOING TO BE A
REPLY BUT RIGHT CAN JUST BE
PAVED OVER BECAUSE SOMEBODY
NEEDS TO PARK ANOTHER CAR. YOU
KNOW I JUST DON'T LIKE THAT TREE
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT SO.
THAT'S THE SORT OF BIG
DIFFERENCE I THINK WE WE.
WANT TO KIND OF.
KEEP OUR FOCUS ON.
URBAN TREES SIMPLY BECAUSE IF
WE.
TAKE OUR EYES OFF OF THEM REALLY
THINGS KIND OF GOING IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION.
AND ESPECIALLY WITH ALL THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA MORTALITY SO
THE. COLTS WATER OAK BORER THAT
CERTAIN AND THAT WHILE THE MARIN
INTERFACE INVASIVE SHUTTLE
BOARDS THAT ARE ALL OVER THE
PLACE FROM.
YES CENTER CITIES ALL THE WAY
OUT TO THE WILDLINGS ALL THOSE
THINGS CONTRIBUTE TO THIS
UNFORTUNATELY WRONG DIRECTION.
INFANTRY CANOPY
SO THAT'S THE SORT OF I WOULD
SORT OF THINK OF IT THAT WAY.
.
HELP IS OF COURSE COMPLETELY
RIGHT TREES  TREES AND I
THINK WE IN THIS ROOM ALL WHITE
OLD TREES.
IT'S JUST THAT.
SOME TREES ARE HAVING A TOUGHER
TIME JUST BY DESIGN AND THOSE
ARE THE URBAN TREES.
IF I CAN JUMP IN AS WELL I
THINK.
PARTOF WHAT WE'RE ALSO SEEING
IS A SWIFT MOVE FOR MORE
INVESTMENT AND. PRACTICES.
IN FIGHTING FIRES AYE AND AND
WE HAVEN'T REALLY GOTTEN TO THE
SPACE OF LEVELING OUT
CONSERVATION EFFORTS AROUND
FORCED ENTRY IS.
WHICH IS JUSTICE IN CENTRAL THE
STRATEGY AND PREPARING AYE FOR
OUR NEW NORMAL IN TERMS OF
CLIMATE IMPACTS THE OTHER THING
I WOULD MENTION IS. ON FUNDING
THE PLANT TREES IS.
AT HIGHER LEVELS THAN
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE FUNDS
FOR TREES.
AND WE NEED TO ESPECIALLY AS AS
PROGRAMS LIKE CAPITA TRADE BEGAN
TO BE A LITTLE MORE FLEXIBLE AND
WE NEED TO START MAKING THAT A
MORE ELIGIBLE PERCENTAGE OF I'VE
PROJECT ALLOCATION COSTS SO
THAT.
I IT IT TO BE A HUGE BURDEN FOR
COMMUNITIES TO HAVE RUNNING THE
PLANT AND THEN TO REALLY
STRUGGLE TO FIND A FUNDING TO AT
MAINTAIN AND. AND SUPPORT.
THEIR TREES LOCALLY SO I THINK
WE REALLY HAVE TO START TO THINK
ABOUT THAT IS ESSENTIAL FOR
PEACE IN THE FORMULA AND I ALSO
JUST WANTED TO. I RESPOND TO
YOUR QUESTION CHAIRMAN GARCIA AS
WELL AROUND THE CLOCK STE WHAT
WOULD IT COST TO DO THIS LEVEL
OF BRIDES BACK TO SPREAD GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE TRANSFORMATION.
WE DON'T HAVE GOOD NUMBERS ON
THAT WE DO HAVE SOME COMMUNITIES
WHO'VE DONE THEIR OWN LOCAL KIND
A NEEDS ASSESSMENT ANALYSIS ON
THE ONE THAT KIND OF IS ISN'T
THE MOST RECENT HAS BEEN LA
COUNTY. WHICH ASSESSED A NEED
FOR GREEN SPACE REGIONALLY AT
OVER TWENTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS
JUST FOR THE COUNTY OF LA.
SO. WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
WHOLE STATE NEEDS IN TERMS OF
WHAT'S THE PRICE TAG TO REALLY
TRANSFORM INFRASTRUCTURE
STATEWIDE BUT WE DO KNOW THERE
ARE SOME LOCALS JURISDICTIONS
THAT HAVE DONE SOME OF THAT
ANALYSIS. AND THAT WAS JUST
BASED ON GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WASN'T BASED ON WATER NEEDS
ARE SOME OF THE OTHER MULTIPLE
BENEFITS OF THESE PROGRAMS THAT
WILL ASK THAT THOSE WHO
ARE GOING TO BE SPEAKING. AT TO
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME.
ORGANIZATION YOU MAY BE
AFFILIATED IF ANY. AND IF YOU
COULD JUST KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO
YOU KNOW MAYBE A MINUTE OR SO
CONSIDERING THAT THERE ARE. A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT WANT TO SPEAK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BALTO SAYING SACRAMENTO REGIONAL
CONSERVATION CORPS I'M THE
DIRECTOR FOR TRAINING PROGRAM.
I'M HERE TO TOUCH UPON THAT
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT ASPECT.
OF FOR BOTH THE EVAN GRINNING AS
WELL AS THE URBAN FORESTRY
PROGRAMS.
BETTER FOURTEEN LOCAL CERTIFIED
CONSERVATION BECAUSE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. AND EACH ONE OF THEM.
ARE WORKING ON VARIOUS PROJECTS
THAT WOULD AGE TO HAVE BEEN
GRINNING ALL EVAN FORESTRY.
THIS PARTICULAR PROJECTS
UP
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
YOUNG ADULTS.
TO.
GAIN JOB SKILLS.
AND.
ALSO.
THIS PROJECT IS SOMEWHAT
DIFFERENT AS WE HEAD THAT MOST
OF THE FUNDING FOR THIS PROJECT
GOES AND UNDERSERVED O..
UNDERPRIVILEGED COMMUNITIES
AND MOST OF OUR PARTICIPANTS
GONE FROM THE SERIOUS.
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL COIL.
CONSERVATION GO IS A RECIPIENT
OF QUALIFY A GUN.
PLANTING NOW FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SIX TREES AND MARYSVILLE
WORKING WITH THAT THE COUNTY
CITY SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND OTHER AGENCIES
AND IN SACRAMENTO.
ALL PARTICIPANTS ARE GOING IN
THE NEIGHBORHOODS.
WHICH I DISADVANTAGED AND WE ARE
TREES ARE NEEDED.
THEY ARE TALKING TO THE
POTENTIAL TREE RECIPIENTS.
AND MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN THE
COMMUNITIES WHY THEY NEED TREES.
AND WHAT'S THE BENEFIT OF THE
TREES AND HOW TO LOCATE THE
TREES.
BUT WHAT WAS DEVELOPMENT THAT
THE COURTS ARE GAINING FROM IS
OUT.
LANDING THE JOB SKILLS
BY NOT ONLY PROBABLY PACKING THE
TREES.
GETTING THE SKILLS TO BE PROPER.
GETTING PROPER KNOWLEDGE OF
UPPER CULTURAL INFORMATION.
THE IRRIGATION TECHNICIANS.
ARE BRINGING.
AND OTHER TREE CARE SO THEY'RE
ABLE TO ENTER JOB MARKETS THAT
ARE PROVIDING JOB OPPORTUNITIES
THAT ARE MORE SUBSTANTIAL RATHER
THAN JUST ENTRY LEVEL JOBS. WE
ARE HELPING THIS PARTICIPANTS TO
ENTER INTO A JOB MARKET SUGGEST
PAYING SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
DOLLARS. SO THEY HAD A PURPOSE
SUSTAIN AND AND PAYING TO MORE
SUSTAINABLE OPPORTUNITIES IN
YEARS TO COME SO THIS PROGRAMS
ARE BENEFITING THE BECAUSE
GREATLY. AND WE DEFINITELY
SUPPORT AND WOULD LIKE THIS
OPPORTUNITIES TO CONTINUE AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL LYNCH ON
BEHALF OF THE LOTS THAT ANGELES
NEIGHBORHOOD LAND TRUST
I AM WE ARE A LA BASED
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION WHO. AYE IS FOCUSED
ON CREATING PARKS AND IT AYE
GREEN SPACES AND COMMUNITY
GARDENS ESPECIALLY IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AND I
WON'T REPEAT AYE THE COMMENTS
THAT MISS ALVES MADE IN REGARDS
TO THE WISHING TREE PARK PROJECT
THAT WE ARE FORTUNATE TO
RECEIVE.
AN AWARD FOR BUT WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS THAT WE ARE VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS PROJECT AS WE ARE
WITH. ALL THE PROJECTS THAT WE
WORK ON BECAUSE IT REALLY IS A
COMMUNITY PROJECTWE MAKE SURE
THAT WE ENGAGE THE COMMUNITY
AND.
IDENTIFYING WHERE THESE PROJECTS
ARE NEEDED HOW THEY SHOULD BE
DEVELOPED WHAT THEY SHOULD LOOK
LIKE WHAT THE FOCUS OF EACH PARK
SHOULD BE. AND THEN IN BUILDINGS
DO WORDS TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
PARKS CONTINUE TO THRIVE AND BE
USED IN THE FUTURE. SO WE'RE
VERY EXCITED FOR.
FOR BEING ABLE TO OFFER THIS
PARK TO THE COMMUNITY I'M IN
TWENTY NINETEEN AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR COMMENTS
REGARDING PASSED THE FIVE AND
THAT THAT.
POLICY WAS NOT INTENDED TO
REPLACE CONTINUED URBAN GREENING
INVESTMENTS IN THE FUTURE WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S A TON OF
PROJECTS THAT ARE STILL NEEDED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND WE'RE
EXCITED TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
YOU AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO. URGE THAT.
CONTINUED URBAN GRINNING
FUNDING CONTINUES TO BE
DISTRIBUTED THROUGHOUT THE CITY
IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMAN GARCIA MY NAME IS
ELEANOR TORRANCE FIRST AND
FOREMOST I AM A RESIDENT FROM A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY. AS WELL
AS A BUSINESS OWNER OF A
DISADVANTAGE MEDIA HAVE
ARCHITECTURAL IN PLANNING FIRM
WITH SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT.
I'M HERE IN THE CAPACITY AS THE
IN.
THERE'S THE CO EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF INCREDIBLE EDIBLE
COMMUNITY GARDENS A RECIPIENT OF
THREE G. DE ARROZ GRANTS.
TOLL OF FORTY TWO HUNDRED TREES
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE WERE
PLANTING. AND WE ARE A TRAINEE
THAT TEAM THAT CARES ABOUT OUR
TREES. OUR FIRST ROUND GRANTS
WERE FOR NEIGHBORHOOD GOAT BUT
DAVID GROWS GRANT AS A MEANS TO
BUILD GREATER CAPACITY
THROUGHOUT THE INLAND EMPIRE. IT
PROVIDE SMALL GRANTS TO TRAIN
COMMUNITIES IN THE COMPETITION
IN THE COMPETITIVENESS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION OF GIGI OR OF
GRANTS. A GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE
TECHNICIAN TRAINING THE TEACHERS
HOW TO CALCULATE CARBON
SEQUESTRATIONTHE VALLEY WITH
THE HELP OF TREES. AND THE RIGHT
TREE FOR THE RIGHT REASONS OUR
TRAINEES IN ENTRANCE RECEIVE
FIFTEEN DOLLARS DOUR AND WE
CONTRACT DISADVANTAGED BUSINESS
OWNERS IN THE COMMUNITIES TO
ALSO WORK WITH US. NONE OF OUR
STAFF RECEIVES A.
A A SALARY.
WE'RE DOING THIS AS A
VOLATILITY BASED GROUP WE MAKE
SURE ALL THE MONEY GOES TO THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THEMSELVES.
.
OUR VOLUNTEERS IN TRAINEES
UNDERSTAND URBAN FORESTRY IT'S
BECOMING A. REALLY IMPORTANT
THING IN OUR COMMUNITY THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT AS BEING THE
RELATIONSHIP OF THE NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT AND THE BUILT
ENVIRONMENT SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES HERE HAVE EXPRESSED.
THE IMPORTANCE AND THE
DIFFERENCE OF URBAN FORESTRY.
VERSUS TRADITIONAL FORESTRY.
.
THE PROGRAM
THE PROGRAMS INCLUDING THE ROUTE
SIXTY SIX VETERANS MEMORIAL
CORRIDOR WHICH PROVIDES A TREE
FOR A VETERAN LIVING OR
DECEASED.
ACTIVE DUTY OR NOT.
WHO ACTUALLY HAS A MARKER ON
EACH OF THE TREES? ALL OF THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE PROVED TO BE
BEYOND JUST THE COSTS OF THE THE
BENEFITS OF THE TREES CHO
BENEFITS ARE FABULOUS. OF WE ARE
SEEING INCREDIBLE WAYS WE CAN
LEVERAGE THINKS.
BUT WHAT WE'RE ALSO SEEING IS
THE SCIENCE THAT WERE ABLE TO
APPROACH THESE TREES AND HOW WE
CAN EDUCATE AND BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER. TO DO THE SAME THING
AND BUILD GREATER CAPACITY THIS
IS WHERE WE'VE SEEN THE GREATEST
USE OF THE SCRIPT.
FINALLY THE REASON WHY I'M HERE
TODAY IS BECAUSE.
I HAD BEEN INVITED THE BUT HAD
BEEN DISINVITED BECAUSE IT WAS A
DETERMINE THAT. SOMEONE FROM THE
ACADEMIC COMMUNITY SHOULD BE.
TESTIFYING WITH YOU BUT.
MY COMMUNITY WAS REALLY EXCITED
BECAUSE INLAND EMPIRE RARELY
GETS A SEAT AT THE TABLE TO
TALK.
AYE I AM FORTUNATE I'M
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE MEMBER FOR THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD.
BUT.
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE WE HAVE THE
LARGEST LAND MASS IN THE UNITED
STATES WE HAVE SOME OF THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN THE
UNITED STATES. AND WE HAVE PRE
MERE PROGRAMS THAT WERE WORKING
WITH TOGETHER LIKE WITH THE CITY
OF COMPTON ACCOMPANIED COLTON
TO.
TO WORK TO REALLY MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES BETTER TO BRING JOBS
TO BRING MORE ECONOMIC HEALTH TO
OUR COMMUNITIES. WE REALLY WANT
TO SEE THAT THE TABLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
ASSEMBLYMAN GARCIA I JUST WANTED
TO SHARE A STORY ABOUT THE CITY
OF COLTON. WE ARE FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND AYE POPULATION A DAC
DISADVANTAGED NINETIETH
PERCENTILE ARE AT THE CALAVERAS
SCREEN SCORE AND WE WENT AFTER
THESE FUNDS BECAUSE AS WAS
MENTIONED THE DEVASTATION OF
HAVING. EXECUTIVE ORDERS TO TURN
OFF YOUR WATER WITHOUT THINKING
OF THE CONSEQUENCES OF THE TREES
SELF SEVERAL OF OUR URBAN FOREST
DIED IMMEDIATELY AND WITH THE
DROUGHT COLTON'S UNIQUE WE GET
ALL OUR WATER STRAIGHT FROM THE
GROUND SO WHEN THE DROUGHT
OCCURRED ALL OF OUR. MATURE
TREES THAT HAD DEEP ROOTS DIED.
AND THEY ALSO GOT IMPACT DID.
AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED FROM A
LOT OF DISEASE SO THE TREES THAT
ARE ALIVE TODAY THEY HAVE A LOT
OF.
MARK DAMAGED AND.
THEY'RE CALLED CLUNK MOLDS ON
THE BOTTOM OF THE ROOTS.
AT THIS POINT THEY'RE HAZARDOUS
TO OUR RESIDENTS AND THEY HAVE
TO BE REMOVED SO IT WAS
IMPORTANT FOR ME TO GET IN URBAN
FORESTRY MANAGEMENT PLAN
BECAUSE.
THAT PLAN EDUCATE SOME CHANGES
ARE ORGAN SAYS SO THAT THERE IS
A STATE ABILITY OF THAT URBAN
FOREST SO THAT IT CONTINUES TO
SEQUESTER CARBON AND THAT WE CAN
HAVE A WHOLE. STOP BUT THE HEAT
ISLAND EFFECT IN OUR CITY WE ARE
ONLY AT A SEVEN PERCENT CANOPY.
BUT WE WILL BE AT A THIRTY
PERCENT HOPEFULLY IN THE NEXT
FEW YEARS JUST BY THAT MASSIVE
EFFORT OF TREE PLANTING AND
CHANGES IN OUR ORDINANCE SAYS
AND JUST WHAT TYPES OF TREES TO
PLANT.
AND ๅซT
OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT WE
WILL NO LONGER PLANT PALM TREES
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFIT TO ANYBODY
THEY DO NOT PROVIDE SHADE DROP
PROVIDE HABITATS IN THEY'RE NOT
CARBON SICK QUESTION. AND
ACTUALLY IN THE CATEGORY AS
GRASSES
SO THAT IS BEEN AN ENTIRE NEW
EDUCATION OUTREACH FOR COMMUNITY
IS JUST WHAT TO PLANT AND
DIVERSITY YOU NEVER WANNA PLANT
SAME TRINA ROWE IN A MEDIAN.
BECAUSE IF SOMETHING HAPPENS TO
ONE THE DISEASE WILL CARRY OUT
TO THE OTHER AT NEW BOSTON
ENTIRE STRING OF TREES.
SO IT'S BEEN AN EXCITING TIME
AND WE HOPE THAT THESE FUNDS
WILL CONTINUE TO COME DOWN TO
OUR NECK OF THE WOODS WE HAVE A
LARGE OF PROJECT. AHEAD OF US
BEEN DISADVANTAGED WE DON'T HAVE
FUNDING TO MATCH AND WE DON'T
HAVE OPPORTUNITIES LIKE THIS.
BUT WE DO HAVE.
AT LEAST THE WELL TO TRY. THINK
IT.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THINKING FOR
DIFFERENT AND I'M GONNA READ
JUST MAKE SURE THAT I DON'T MISS
IMPORTANT POINTS HERE. IMPETUS I
CAN LOG ON THE PRINCIPLE IT IS
TOO DUMB LA. LANDSCAPE
ARCHITECTURE FIRM BASED IN AND
LOS ANGELES AND SAN FRANCISCO.
COMMITTED TO CREATING VIBRANT
RESILIENT PLACES FOR DESIGN AND
ADVOCACY I URGE YOU TO MAINTAIN
GROW THIS URBAN GRINNING AND
CLIMATE ADAPTATION PROGRAMS AS
VITAL. RESOURCES TO INVESTING IN
LOW INCOME. AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WITH MULTI BENEFIT GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE WE HAVE SEEN
FIRSTHAND THE POSITIVE IMPACTS
OF THESE PROGRAMS.
WHERE BLIGHTED COMMUNITIES ONCE
COLLECTED TRASH POLLUTION IN
CRIME THEIR KNOWLEDGE TREE LINE
STREETS?
A FUTURE IN THE AIR AND WATER
AND ATTRACTING LIFE AND
COMMUNITY WHERE ALSO IT MOVES
PRETTY THAT HEAT AND COLLECTED.
PARTICULATES THERE ARE NOW
CHILDREN PLAYING NATURAL
LANDSCAPES.
AND SHE'D BEEN IN KUWAIT SHE'S
INSPIRED BY THE WILDLIFE AROUND
THEM.
THIS PROGRAMS PROVIDE UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE
MOBILITY HEALTH.
AND THE SAFETY IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS MOST IN NEED OF
INVESTMENT INFRASTRUCTURE AND
HOPE.
THIS PROGRAMS REDUCE THE HEAT
ISLAND EFFECT CAPTIONING IN OUR
WATER SEQUESTER CARBON INCLUDE
ALL WHERE PROVIDE ACTIVE LEAVING
AND COME BACK ILLNESS AND
OBESITY. AND ARE KEY TO BUILDING
A RESILIENT HEALTH FUTURE FOR
ALL OF US THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AARON
EVANS WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES HERE TO LEND
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE URBAN
GRINNING AND URBAN FORESTRY
PROGRAMS. AS THE STATE WORKS
TOWARDS ACHIEVING ITS CLIMATE
CHANGE ON GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS REDUCTION GOALS WE NOW
THAT CITIES ARE VERY IMPORTANT
PARTNERS IN THAT EFFORT.
I'M IN FACT.
THIS PROGRAM THESE PROGRAMS
REALLY ARE GREAT EXAMPLES OF THE
COLLABORATION THAT CAN BE FORGED
BETWEEN THE STATE LEVEL AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
AND WE'VE SEEN THIS IN MULTIPLE
WAYS FOR EXAMPLE.
.
THESE PROGRAMS PROMOTE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT BECAUSE THE
COMMUNITIES ARE WORKING WITH
LOCAL OFFICIALS TO ENSURE THAT
PROGRAMS ARE DEVELOPED THAT WILL
IMPROVE THE COMMUNITIES.
SECOND WE HAVE THE IMPROVEMENT
OF THE COMMUNITIES BY
IMPLEMENTING THE PROGRAMS
INCLUDING WITH AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. AND FINALLY I AS
THE STATE BECAUSE OUR HOPES TO
UP WHAT WE AS CITIES HOPE TO
HELP TO GET CLOSER TO ACHIEVING
THE STATE CALLS BY REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
AS SUCH THESE GRANT PROGRAMS ARE
VERY IMPORTANT TO COMMUNITIES.
THAT THAT WOULDN'T OTHERWISE BE
ABLE TO ACCESS FUNDING TO
IMPLEMENT SUCH PROGRAMS AND SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE SUPPORT THE
PROGRAM AND THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING TODAY.
MISTER CHAIR MARK FENCE MAKE ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA URBAN
FOREST COUNCIL. STRONG
SUPPORTERS LONGTIME SUPPORTERS
OF THE URBAN FORESTRY PROGRAM AT
CAL FIRE. WE SUPPORT OF THE PARK
RUN THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS LAST YEAR AND WE AGREE
WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR THESE
DOLLARS AND PARK PLAN BOND
SHOULD BE ADDITIVE NOT
REPLACEMENTS TO WITH A CAP AND
TRADE DOLLARS HAVE BEEN. AND THE
PROGRAM CLEARLY NEEDS IT AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER THE PROGRAM'S
BEEN OVERSUBSCRIBED BY FOUR
HUNDRED PERCENT LAST YEAR. TO
ONE OF THE BEST MOST EFFICIENT
JG REDUCTION PROGRAMS ON A
DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR BASIS.
I'M IN JUST ONE AT REFLECT ONE
OTHER ECHO ONE COMMENT FROM
EARLIER CAN NEED TO START
INVESTING IN SOME OF THE TREE
MAINTENANCE.
THERE'S A LOT OF MENTION OF PASS
SHOP HOPE BORDER IT'S A GROWING
AND VERY SERIOUS ISSUE THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON TRYING TO
DRESS.
A BIG THREAT TO URBAN POOR SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
ON TRYING TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
TORRANCE ON A BIT OF THE
DIRECTOR OF ENGAGEMENT EDUCATION
OF THE SACK WHEN A TREE
FOUNDATIONS SO.
WE ARE VERY PROUD OF THE CANOPY
THAT WE HAVE IN THE CITY AND IT
IS BASED ON LONG TERM INVESTMENT
FROM. ON THE FOUNDERS OF THIS
CITY TO TOM OR LOCAL UTILITY AND
FROM ON THE STATE I'M CURRENTLY
ARE THE RECIPIENTS OF TWO
DIFFERENT CAL FIRE GRANTS.
ONE ENABLES US TO WORK WITH OUR
PARTNERS AT THE CONSERVATION
CORPS AND ITS WELL WORN FARMS TO
PLANT THREE THOUSAND TREES. ON
IN SOUTH SACRAMENTO WHICH IS THE
MOST UNDER CANOPY PART OF
SACRAMENTO.
IN IT ALLOWS US TO DO IT TO A
MODEL THAT BUILDS COMMUNITY
INTERCONNECTEDNESS AND IT'S
ESSENTIAL THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO
DO IT FOR THAT MODEL BECAUSE
THAT'S THE WAY THAT YOU ENSURE
LONG TERM SURVIVABILITY OF THE
TREES.
AND ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE TO FEEL MORE IN FRANCHISE
BY THEIR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
ON THE OTHER PROGRAMS ACTUALLY
QUITE NEAT IT'S SOME FUNDED
THROUGH THE GREEN INNOVATIONS
PROGRAM IT'S URBAN WOULD RESCUE.
SOME PROGRAMS HAVE BASICALLY
RIGHT NOW WHEN TREES HAVE TO
COME DOWN LIKE MANY OF A MATURE
TREES IN SACRAMENTO.
THEIR LANDFILL BOUNDS NAM BUT
WE'RE ACTUALLY BUILDING A MAIL
IN SOUTH SACRAMENTO SOMEWHERE WE
CAN HARVEST THAT WOULD IN
SELATAN ARTISANAL MARKET.
WHICH ALLOWS PEOPLE TO YOU KNOW
KEEP THESE TREES THAT MAY BE
IMPORTANT TO THEM CREATES A
WHOLE NEW PROFIT CENTER ALLOWS
FOR JOBS TO BE CREATED AN
INDUSTRY THAT WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED OTHERWISE BECAUSE. YOU
KNOW UP UNTIL NOW NOBODY REALLY
THOUGHT THIS IS SOMETHING IT
DESERVED INVESTMENT BUT FOLKS A
CALIFORNIA.
THROUGH THIS PROCESS YOU KNOW
DREAM THIS UP AND WE'RE
INNOVATING SOMETHING THAT WILL
CREATE GREATER.
EFFICIENCIES SOON ENOUGH FOR
OTHER PEOPLE TO REPLICATE SO
WITHOUT PROGRAMS LIKE THIS
WITHOUT THE THE KNOWLEDGE IN THE
WHERE WITH ALL OF OF
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE HELLFIRE
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO SEE PROGRAMS
LIKE THIS GET STARTED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS FATIMA
AND PUTTING ON A LEAK AND I'M A
RESIDENT OF DA PASO HEIGHTS IN
OUR SACRAMENTO. OF FIRST I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT OF THAT ARE
BEGINNING EVAN FOR SHE PROGRAMS.
AND I JUST WANT TO SHARE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE WORK THAT
WE'VE BEEN HONOR TO PARTICIPATE
IN IN OUR SACRAMENTO THROUGH A
PARTNERSHIP THANKS TO THE RELIEF
FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVE THROUGH
THE PLANTING WHAT PURPOSE GRANT.
ON THIS THIS COLLABORATIVE.
.
GOING TO SHARE A LOT ABOUT A NOR
SACRAMENTO IT'S HISTORICALLY IT
DOESN'T DIS INVESTED
NEIGHBORHOOD AND SO.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE GET
INVESTMENT. IN IMPROVING THE
URBAN GREENING OF PHYSICAL
ENVIRONMENT AND BEAUTIFICATION
THAT IS NEEDED TO REALLY
REHABILITATE OUR COMMUNITY.
THAT UPPERSIDES GROWERS
ALLIANCE WHICH IS.
COMMITTED TO URBAN PLANNING
EFFORTS BECAUSE OF THEIR POINTS
IN IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF LIFE
FACTORS THAT SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ISN'T DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
HAS TO DATE PLANTED AT LEAST.
SIXTY TREES ARE THIRTY IN ONE
PART AND ABOUT TWENTY IN A
COMMUNITY GARDEN BUT WHAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT IS THAT WE'RE
NOT JUST POINTING SHADE TREES
WERE ALSO PLANTING FRUIT TREES.
UP BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS IS IN
NEIGHBORHOODS LIKE LIKE THE ONE
I LIVE IN A WE GET THIS DOUBLE
WHAMMY OF NOT ONLY THE HEAT
ISLAND EFFECT BUT ALSO THIS WHO
DOES IT AS YOU KNOW. AS WE GET
REALLY POOR QUALITY FOOD AND
JUST POOR QUALITY LIVING
ENVIRONMENTS FROM AIR AND FOOD
AND JUST EVERYTHING SO IS REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE LEARN HOW TO.
UP POINT SHE'S NOT JUST FOR
SHAPE PURPOSES BUT FOR FOOD
PURPOSES AS WELL. AND.
ALSO.
TO SPEAK ON A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHAT I'VE HEARD TODAY IT'S.
YOU KNOW ONE BEING NOTIFIED AS
THE COMMUNION RAIL THESE
OPPORTUNITIES IMPORTANT INTO
LEARNING HOW TO EVEN PARTICIPATE
IN THE PROCESS SO WE'VE BEEN
REALLY HONORED TO HAVE SUPPORT
FROM. A LOT OF DIFFERENT NON
PROFITS AND I JUST WANT TO SHARE
A LITTLE BIT OF EACH PARTNER'S
ROLE SPECIFIC HOUSING
INCORPORATED WHICH IS A LOCAL
NONPROFIT DEVELOPER. HAS BEEN
ABLE TO BE THE THE LEAD AGENCY
THAT CAN ACTUALLY AFFORD TO.
BE REIMBURSED FOR THE FINDING
THAT.
THIS GRANT ALLOWS FOR AND
THROUGH THAT THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO PARKS AND RECREATION
DEPARTMENT HAS.
PROVIDE PERMISSION TO PLANTS
ON THEIR PUBLIC PROPERTY WHICH
ARE PUBLIC PARKS AND AS YOU KNOW
A LOT OF THE CITY PARK
DEPARTMENTS HAVE LOW OR NO
RESOURCES. TO MAINTAIN THEIR
PARTS OF THIS IS A GREAT
PARTNERSHIP.
AND THEN THE SECOND NOT CHEAT
FOUNDATION HAS BEEN INTEGRAL IN
HELPING US.
RECRUIT VOLUNTEERS WHO HAD AT
LEAST LEAST SEVENTY FIVE
VOLUNTEERS LAST APRIL WERE
PLANNING. TO BIG EVENTS THIS
MARCH AND APRIL AS WELL SO WILL
CONTINUE THIS ANNUAL EVENT NOW.
TO HAVE MORE MORE PEOPLE GET
INVOLVED THE JUSTICES NETWORK
HAS BEEN AN AMAZING DOT PARTNER.
TO HELP US THINK THROUGH JUST
HOW DO WE ENGAGE WITH THE
COMMUNITY EFFECTIVELY AND
RESPECTFULLY.
AND THEN GREEN TECH GREEN
TECHNICAL EDUCATION EMPLOYMENT
HAS BEEN INTEGRAL IN PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES TO YOUNG BROWN AND
BLACK YOUTH.
PREDOMINANTLY OF BOYS AND MEN
OF COLOR I'M EXPOSING THEM TO
NOT ONLY LEARNING TREES PLANTING
TREES.
BUT WE HAVE TEENAGERS WHO HAVE
NEVER EVEN EIGHT AN ASIAN PEAR
AND TO ME THAT IS A TRAGEDY THAT
WE HAVE TO CHANGE IN THE ONLY
WAY WE CAN DO THAT IS TO
OPPORTUNITIES LIKE THIS SO ON I
THINK YOU.
THANK YOU TERRACE THEATRE
CROWDED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL WHERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE STATE'S
URBAN GRINNING IN URBAN FORESTRY
PROGRAMS. I'M AS YOU HEARD FOR
MY COLLEAGUES THESE PROGRAMS
PROVIDE A MULTITUDE OF CO
BENEFITS PARTICULARLY IN PARK
OR.
I UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES WE
SUPPORT RESTORING SHOULD EUROPE
FUNDING FOR THESE PROGRAMS WHEN
THOSE DISCUSSIONS ROLL AROUND.
I'M ASKING HEARD THESE PROGRAMS
ARE VASTLY OVER SUBSCRIBED.
AND OFFER A NUMBER OF BENEFITS
TED DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND WE LOOK TO SEIZE WITHOUT A
FUNDING RESTORED THINKING.
HI I'M MARIA DE LEรณN WITH THAT
GRASSROOTS NONPROFIT CALLED FROM
LOT TO SPOT BASED IN LOS
ANGELES.
WE ARE A.
NONPROFIT THAT BUILDS COMMUNITY
DESIGNED GREEN SPACES AND ALL
THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES AND.
WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY BUT REALLY PLEAD
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THESE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE NOT A LUXURY FOR OUR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IT'S A
DIRE NECESSITY. FOR COMMUNITIES
LIKE LENNIX THE COMPANY THAT I
GREW UP IN THAT WE WHERE
FORTUNATE.
ENOUGH TO BE.
GRANTED.
AN AWARD THROUGH CAL FIRES
PROGRAM.
TO PLANT SEVENTY FIVE NEW TREES
IN THE COMMUNITY OF LENNOX ON
FOR THOSE OF YOU NOT FAMILIAR
WITH LEN EXITS AN UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITY AND LAW LA COUNTY. AND
LIKE OTHER DANCE LOW INCOME
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IT'S
OVER BRING BY POLLUTION POLEMICS
LIFE CHILES LOCATED UNDERNEATH
THE LANDING PATH OF THE LA
ACCENT SURROUNDED BY TO FREEWAYS
THERE'S A FROM OIL REFINERY
REALLY NEARBY AND. THE OCEAN
BREEZE STUFFED.
BURDENS LENNIX WITH ARM.
INTENSE POLLUTION AND WE DON'T
HAVE AN EXISTING TREE CANOPY SO
WE WERE ABLE TO PLAN SEVENTY
FIVE NEW TREES UP NOT ONLY THAT
BUT IT WAS COMMUNITY. WHERE
LOCAL STUDENTS WHO ACTUALLY WENT
DOOR TO DOOR TO CONVINCE
RESIDENTS TO ADOPT THE TREES AND
WATER THEM WHILE THE COUNTY DID
THE LONG TERM MAINTENANCE?
ARE ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THE
PROJECT WE WERE RECENTLY FUNDED
THROUGH ARE BEGINNING IS AND
WHAT'S WHERE WE WILL BE ABLE TO
PLANT MORE TREES AS WELL TO
INCREASE THE.
TOUCHY CANOPY AND SICK.
ALSO BUILDING GARDEN SO WILL
HELP CAPTURE WATER AND IF WHICH
A WATER WITH NATIVE PLANTS BUT
THESE ARE JUST SOME EXAMPLES OF
PROJECTS THAT ARE REALLY. THE
BASIC NECESSITIES ARE NOT.
A LUXURY AND WE WE PLEASE THAT
YOU SUPPORT THEM THINK.
GOOD AFTERNOON DAVID TAO WILL
CONCERNED I'M DONE.
PRESIDENT OF THE LITTLE ENTRY
FOUNDATION NOT JUST ACROSS THE
RIVER IN YOLO COUNTY. FOUNDED A
TWO YEARS AGO IT'S ALL VOLUNTEER
DRIVEN.
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORTING THE URBAN FORESTRY
PROGRAM.
VOLUNTEERS ARE PUTTING IT TO
GET WORK JUST A COUPLE OF
QUICK-EXAMPLES.
I WILL BE PLANNING TWELVE
HUNDRED TREES AS VOLUNTEERS.
ON SATURDAY.
AT A MOBILE HOME PARK. THERE
WAS A GANG RELATED MURDER ABOUT
A YEAR AND A HALF AGO.
COMMUNITIES COMING OUT SATURDAY
TO PLANT TREES IN THE.
PLAY AREA.
THIS'LL INVOLVE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS
OUR RESIDENTS SHOWN AND OTHER
VOLUNTEERS THE FOLLOWING
SATURDAY WERE. PLANNING FIFTY
TREES OTHER. PUBLIC HOUSING
FACILITY BUILT THE FIFTIES.
THAT.
HAS A LOT OF OLD DYING TREES
IT'LL PROVIDE OFFER SHADE FOR
THOSE RESIDENTS.
ROTARY IS COMING OUT TO PLANT
THOSE TREES.
AT KNOW IF YOU KNOW BUT ROTARY
UNDER NATIONAL WAS CHALLENGED.
EACH SHARE ROTARIAN.
A PLAN AT LEAST ONE TREE THIS
YEAR. SO AUTRY'S SO AGAIN THANK
YOU ARE WE COULD DO IT WITHOUT
YOUR HELP. THE CITY'S A BIG
PARTNER.
SO THE STATE'S RESOURCES ARE
LEVERAGING TREMENDOUS
VOLUNTEERISM.
AND A LOT OF LOCAL DOLLARS TO.
KEEP OUR STATE HEALTHY AND GREEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU FOR CONVENING THIS AND
THANK YOU FOR.
STAYING WITH US TO THIS AND.
LEE HEIRESS WHO TREE FRESNO
WE'VE BEEN AROUND SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY THREE YEARS
NOW. AND WE PLANTED OVER FORTY
THREE THOUSAND TREES.
AND THANKS TO THE FUNDING THAT'S
BECOME AVAILABLE THROUGH
CALIFORNIA ARE.
AND LOCAL INITIATIVES WE HOPE TO
REACH FIFTY THOUSAND TREES
BEFORE TOO LONG.
I WANTED TO RESPOND TO A COUPLE
THE QUESTIONS THAT CAME UP LIKE
WHAT WE DO MORE.
ALL WE ARE NOW CONDUCTING A TREE
INVENTORY AND FRESNO THROUGH CAL
FAR GRANT.
THAT'S GONNA SHOW WATER TREE
LOSSES WERE IN THE PARKS AND ON
STREET TREES.
AND FOR WHAT I'M HEARING THAT'S
GOING TO BE OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND.
SPROUT IT'S EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT TODAY. AND
THAT DOESN'T BEGIN TO ADDRESS.
THE FACT THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH TREES PLANTED IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
SO IT IS SIGNIFICANT.
WELL ONE REASON WHY I'M HERE IS
WE BEEN THE RECIPIENT OF THREE
GRANTS.
FUNDED THROUGH THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM. OF THE FIRST ONE WAS TO
CALIFORNIA RELIEF WHERE WE PLAY
IT.
TREES AT TWELVE DIFFERENT SCHOOL
CAMPUSES.
AND WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU
THAT WE THINK THAT WHEN WE
PLANET OF THE SCHOOL ARE OUR
ALLIES PROBABLY THE HIGHEST.
IS NOT ONLY DO YOU HAVE THE
PHYSICAL BENEFIT OF THE TREE
PUTS AN INSTRUCTIONAL BENEFIT.
AS WELL AS CONTRIBUTING TO THE
ATMOSPHERE FOR LEARNING.
AND OFTEN WHEN WE'RE ADDED
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL. WILL HAVE
THIRTY CHILDREN.
COMING OUT TO HELP THIS PLANET
EACH TREE.
AND THE A SOMEWHAT ADOPTED. IN
THAT PROCESS
AND DEPENDING ON THEIR AGE WE
CAN TALK ABOUT THE BENEFITS.
BUT THEY ALL APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT IT'S PLACE FOR BURGER LAND.
BUT THEY ALSO ENJOY LEARNING
ABOUT THE SPECIES AND WHAT SOME
OF THE OTHER BENEFITS ARE GONNA
DO.
I ALSO WANNA JUST. ADD.
TO THE IMPORTANCE OF CANOPY
SOMETIMES THESE THINGS CAN MAYBE
SEEMED ABSTRACT.
YOU HEARD THE REPRESENTATIVE OF.
CALIFORNIA OR SPEAK TO FIFTEEN
PERCENT STATEWIDE WE JUST HAD A.
STUDY DONE OF OUR PARK SYSTEM
MANY OF OUR PARKS ONLY HAVE
ELEVEN PERCENT.
CANOPY.
AND WILL WERE PLEASED TO SEE
THAT CALIFORNIA IS PART OF THE
REVISED MISSION
IT'S GONNA BE LOOKING AT THE
CANOPY FOR EACH REGION.
NOT ENCOURAGE YOU TO FUND THAT
AND WEEKLY LIKE TO BE PART OF
THE SOLUTION TO IMPROVE THAT
CANOPY.
THANK YOU.
TRYING TO STAY WITHIN THE ONE
MINUTE TIMEFRAME.
I DIDN'T REALIZE IT WAS A ONE
THE THE SCENE WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
WE WORK IN THAT PRIMARILY IN
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY COACHELLA
VALLEY WITH LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES A LOT OF
DISADVANTAGE UNINCORPORATED
AREAS. AND WE.
ECHO EVERYBODY SUPPORT FOR BOTH
PROGRAMS EXTRA CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. FOR COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ESPECIALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE A PART.
POR IT CETERA DID A COUPLE
THINGS THAT CAN OF AS THE
PROGRAM PROGRESSES WEEKLY SIZE
OBSTACLES IN SOME OF THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED AREAS WAS A
REQUIREMENT FOR A FRIEND CUT
CAPITAL. ON THAT KEPT SOME FOLKS
FROM APPLYING ARE COMPETING AND
THEN THE REQUIREMENT FOR ON
GOING ME THAT THE LACK OF
FLEXIBILITY AROUND ONGOING
MAINTENANCE. AND TRYING TO MAKE
THAT MORE FLEXIBLE TO ALLOW
VOLUNTEER HOURS.
TO TO QUALIFY OR ADDED TO COVER
THE COSTS OF LIKE ENGINEERING
STUDIES SO THAT THERE CAN BE AN
ASSESSMENT. SOMETHING ALONG
THOSE LINES SO THAT FOLKS CAN
SECURE THE.
SOME MECHANISM FOR MAINTENANCE
THAT'S NOT BEYOND THEIR REACH.
THANKS SO MUCH.
ONE OF THE MADONNA WITHOUT ON
CALIFORNIA FOR THE REASONS.
PREVIOUSLY STATED WE SUPPORT OF
THIS PROGRAM IT ALSO IN ADDITION
TO THAT.
THIS PROGRAM REALLY ALLOWS OF
FOR OUR IRVINE I AREAS TO HAVE
URBAN HABITAT FOR URBAN BIRDS
SO.
FOR THOSE REASONS WE SUPPORT
THIS.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON UNLESS I'M
JUST WITH THE GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE.
DIRECTOR OF ENVIRONMENTAL
EQUITY AND AS SUCH WE PROMOTE UP
PROGRAMS THAT PROMOTE PEOPLE
PLANET AND PROSPERITY URBAN
FORESTRY AND I'VE BEEN READING
DO ALL OF THOSE THREE THINGS.
AND I JUST WANNA HIGHLIGHT THAT.
I THINK YOU'VE HEARD A LOT OF
SUPPORT IN A LOT OF STATISTICS
ABOUT THE BENEFITS OF THESE
PROGRAMS.
END OF SOBRE SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN CAP AND TRADE REVENUE
ONLY A HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED TO BOTH OF THESE
PROGRAMS COMBINED.
SO A LOT OF GREAT BENEFITS FOR
NOT A LOT OF FUNDING.
AND I THINK THAT SPEAKS TO JUST
HOW MUCH BENEFIT THESE PROGRAMS
GENERATE.
HOW MY KNEE CHO BENEFITS IT DOES
HIGH AND HOW THE INVESTMENT IS
ACTUALLY NOT THAT HIGH?
SO THE FACT THAT BOTH OF THESE
PROGRAMS IN THE CURRENT PROPOSAL
ARE AT ZERO ISRAELI
UNACCEPTABLE.
I THINK THAT ALL OF THESE
BENEFITS ARE NOT GONNA CONTINUE
TO OCCUR IF WE RELY ON S. B.
FIVE FUNDING SO THAT'S WHY I'M
BRINGING THESE PROGRAMS UP IN
THE CURRENT BUDGET CYCLE AND
FUTURE CURRENT LAW BUDGET CYCLES
AS WITH IMPORTANT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
A PLEASURE TO BE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON WE WANT TO THANK YOU
AND YOUR COLLEAGUES FOR THIS
HEARING. AND YOUR PERSONAL
INTEREST IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
MY NAME IS GENE BIGLER AYE
REPRESENT POINT DATES A
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATION STOCKTON.
WE'RE BENEFICIARIES OF TWO OF
THESE PROGRAMS WON THROUGH CAL
RELIEF AND THE OTHER THROUGH CAL
FIRE.
THAT HAVE ENABLED US TO BEGIN
THE RESTORATION OF THE URBAN
CANOPY IN STOCKTON.
BUT THE EFFORT IS ENORMOUS
BECAUSE.
BOB MANY OF THE THE THINGS THAT
ARE WITNESSES OF CITED IN THESE
HEARINGS THIS MORNING.
AND THE DIFFICULTY IN ADJUSTING.
ARMED TO THE RECOVERY EFFORT
MEANS THAT WE NEED MAXIMUM
FLEXIBILITY. IN THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR THE DIFFERENT
PROJECTS THAT ARE NEEDED IN
ORDER TO RESTORE A TREE CANOPY.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THAT
MEANS A SPECIALLY IT'S FUNDING
THAT WILL HELP US MOVE TOWARD
DEVELOPING MAINTENANCE PROGRAMS.
IT ISN'T ENOUGH TO SAY THAT WE
JUST WON'T FUND MAINTENANCE
BUT IF AT LEAST WEGOT FUNDING
TO HELP US DEVELOP MECHANISMS
FOR MAINTENANCE WE CAN DO A LOT
MORE IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME
AND EFFORT AND I CONCURRENT OUT
SALUTE ALL OF THE WITNESSES THAT
YOU'VE HAD TODAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOSH WAS STUCK
WITH TRANSFORM.
WHERE ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
SUSTAINABLE AND EQUITABLE
TRANSPORTATION AND LAND USE
POLICIES?
AND WE FIND THAT THEY URBAN
GRADING ARE WOULD FORESTRY
COMPONENTS ARE ABSOLUTELY VITAL
FOR INTEGRATED STRATEGIES IN IN
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE AND
IMPROVING JUST IMPROVING
COMMUNITIES AND WE TALK A LOT
ABOUT. YOU KNOW I HEAR A LOT OF
OF STATISTICS I HEAR A LOT OF
YOU KNOW TALK ABOUT CANOPY COVER
IT SEPARATES HEADER BUT. REALLY
VISCERALLY THIS ALSO HAS A REAL
CONNECTION TO HUMANS ON THE
GROUND AND THESE ARE REAL
PHYSICAL IMPROVEMENTS TO
COMMUNITIES THAT CAN BE MADE ARE
YOU KNOW RELATIVELY
INEXPENSIVELY BUT DO NEED TO BE
MAINTAINED OVER TIME.
AND SO WE WE FULLY SUPPORT
THESE PROGRAMS THANK.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON AFTER POSTING
ANY IN HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA LOCKS.
WHERE STATEWIDE NONPROFIT THAT
WORKS TO ADVANCE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION OPPORTUNITIES AND
PEDESTRIAN ACTIVITY I'M AND
THESE TWO PROGRAMS THAT YOU
HEARD ABOUT TODAY THEIR URBAN
READING AN URBAN FORESTRY ARE
ONES THAT DEFINITELY HELPED TO
PROMOTE? AND NOT ONLY ACTIVE IN
THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES BUT
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES AND YOU
HEARD FROM A FEW AT THE SPEAKERS
TODAY AND I'M. FROM THE VALLEY
AND SO I KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF
THESE PROGRAMS AND I
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SITE
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THESE
THINGS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT BEING
THE LAST SPEAKER I JUST WOULD
LIKE TO.
ONCE AGAIN THANK ALL OF THE
PALACE THAT WERE HERE WITH US.
THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE SPOKEN
DURING THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEGMENT AND THAT CLEARLY YOU
KNOW MY INTERESTS IS.
ARE THERE TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
SOME RECURRING FUNDING IT'S
CLEAR THAT THERE THERE NEEDS TO
BE MORE. AND.
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL OF YOU TO PURSUING.
A FUNDING STREAM I IN THIS NEXT
FISCAL BUDGET.
THAT BEING SAID THIS IS A
MATTER THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO SOME FOLLOW UP A
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT. IN AGAIN
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR OUT FOR
BEING HERE THIS AFTERNOON.
SPINNING IS OBJECT.
THERE